Das Märchen ist erfüllt nicht nur von sozialer Utopie, also des besseren Lebens und der Gerechtigkeit, sondern es hat auch technische Utopien, vor allem in orientalischen Märchen als das Zauberpferd in 1001 Nacht. Da gibt es sogar einen Auf- und Abstieghebel, dass ein Hubschrauber im Zauberpferd...
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 74. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer weiteren Ausgabe in dem Podcast, wo es um Dinge geht, die ihr noch nie wissen wolltet, aber jetzt trotzdem beigebracht bekommt, weil ihr zugeschaltet habt bei Chaosradio Express. Wir haben den 12. Februar 2008 und für heute habe ich mir einen, auf den ersten Blick vielleicht gar nicht so tiefgründiges Thema ausgesucht, was nicht desto trotz schon interessant ist. Das Thema ist Hubschrauber oder sind Hubschrauber. Belebt wird das Ganze allerdings durch meinen heutigen Gast und ich darf vorstellen Heinrich Dubel. Hallo, Heinrich.
Hallo Tim.
Man nennt dich Rosa.
Man, ja, manche würde ich sagen, nicht alle. Nennst du dich selber Rosa? Nein, ich nenne mich selber nicht Rosa, jedenfalls nicht mehr beziehungsweise nur den gegenüber, die mich auch Rosa nennen. Das ist eine Art Time-Codierung. Niemand, den ich nicht vor 1991 gekannt habe, darf mich überhaupt Rosa nennen.
Oh, jetzt muss ich gleich noch mal drüber nachdenken, wie lange ich dich schon kenne. Aber du warst schon mal auch mit diesem Namen, deswegen habe ich das auch aufgebracht, denn so steht es in den Analen. Unter anderem angekündigt als Vortragender auf einem unserer Kongresse. Und da ging es um ein ganz anderes Thema. Das war nämlich der 17C3, damals noch im guten Haus am kölnischen Park. Da ging es um die Einführung in die Eratik. Und was mich gerade komplett nach hinten umgeworfen hat, ist der Zusatzbegriff, den du in Deinen Klammern noch dahinter gesetzt hast. Erinnerst Du Dich?
Präpedeokum, oder was das war? Das hast Du dahinter geschrieben.
Performatives Propedeutikum.
Genau, genau.
Ich habe das dahinter geschrieben. Du hast es nicht dahinter geschrieben. Ich weiß ja noch nicht mal, was das ist.
Wenn Du es nicht weißt, ich weiß es auch nicht. Okay, lass mich deine erste Frage aufnehmen, Rosa. Wenn es jetzt schon mal raus ist, muss es auch abgehandelt werden. Anders kann man damit nicht umgehen. Das stimmt, man muss arbeiten. Rosa war früher, also ganz früher, wir sprechen hier von einem Zeitraum von circa in den 70ern oder sogar 80ern, kein Mensch weiß das genau. Punk, ja, ich habe Punk erfunden in Deutschland, neu.
Du warst das?
Ich war das, genau. Und zwar gab es seinerzeit, ich weiß nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt, das heißt Hannover, das ist circa 300 Kilometer westlich von Berlin.
Ich habe davon schon mal gehört.
Ja, genau. Dort jedenfalls habe ich den deutschen Punk neu erfunden und das muss so um 79, 80 gewesen sein. Und die Band, die ich zu diesem Zwecke gegründet habe, benannte ich der Schlichtheit halber Rosa. Nach unserem großen Vorbild, der bis heute vollkommen unbekannt gebliebenen und vermutlich zu Recht großen britischen Punkband Rosa Jemen. Die Überlegung war einfach. Wir brauchten in Smash einen Namen. Wir waren noch nicht alt genug, um uns selber was Richtiges auszudenken, haben uns also inspirieren lassen. Unsere Inspiration hieß Rosa Jemen. Wir dachten, Jemen, das ist doch kein Name für ein Punkband. Außerdem heißt ja ein Land schon so. Rosa, das ist ein Name für eine Punkband. Und also nannten wir uns Rosa. Nun war es seinerzeit aber so, dass alle Punks sogenannte Straßen- oder Kriegsnamen hatten. Mein Mitmusiker hieß LSD, der andere hieß Bone, wieder einer hieß Kartoffel, nur ich. Ich hatte überhaupt keinen Punk-Straßennamen. Ich hatte nur den Namen, unter dem ich später als Wissenschaftler bekannt werden sollte, Heinrich Dubel. Und das war ja nun wirklich überhaupt kein Punk-artiger Name.
Schon gar nicht in der Zeit?
Schon gar nicht in der Zeit. Nun passierte das Folgende. Unsere damaligen Aktionen, mit denen wir den deutschen Punk neu erfanden, waren so fantastisch, dass sämtliche norddeutschen Fanscenes darüber berichteten. Da Heinrich in Norddeutschland aber ein weit verbreiteter Name ist und ungefähr 50 Prozent der norddeutschen Punks alle Heinrich hießen, so bekam ich von den Schreiberlingen seiner Zeit den suffix Rosa verpasst, um mich von den anderen Heinrichen zu unterscheiden, nämlich als denjenigen von der Punk-Band Rosa. Rosa Heinrich. Das ging so weit, dass mein eigentlicher Name Heinrich hinter dem Namen Rosa verblasste. Und in dieser ganzen Zeit war ich dann immer der Rosa. Und ich wurde auch so vorgestellt und immer so weiter und immer so weiter. Das greift um sich.
Da kann man wenig machen. Das ist doch schön, wenn etwas hinter dem Rosa verblasst.
Hinter dem Rosa verblasst. Besonders wenn es so etwas ist wie Heinrich.
Aber was hat es denn nun mit der Eratik auf sich? Du bist ja auch Vertreter des, soll man sagen, Gründer? Was bist du denn eigentlich?
Ich bin der Gründer.
Du bist der Gründer des Eratik-Institutes?
Ja, Eratik-Institut Berlin.
Eratik-Institut Berlin, genau. Und diese Eratik, die hast du auch auf dem Kongress eingeführt?
Genau.
Oder hast du Leute eingeführt in die Eratik?
Ich habe die Eratik in die Leute eingeführt. Wir sind sozusagen eine klandestin operierende Gruppe, deren äußere Körperschaft das Eratik-Institut ist. Eine Gruppe aus Literaten, Kulturwissenschaftlern, Musikern, auch Popmusikern. Leute, die eigentlich im öffentlichen Leben stehen oder in der öffentlichen Forschung, die aber ansonsten nicht damit behelligt werden wollen. Oder die nicht möchten, dass bekannt wird, dass sie sich mit Abseitigen beschäftigen. Also hat man so eine Art klandestine Körperschaft entwickelt, die Aktivitäten dieser Körperschaft werden so von mir koordiniert. Und unter Verschluss gehalten.
Die Eratik ist eine, wie du sagst, Methode des Verbindens eigentlich unverbundener Dinge?
Ja, Assoziativ, Assoziation des disparaten Manns. Das ist wie eine Art Technik. Eine Zusammenschau von Sachen, die halt nicht wirklich zusammengehören. Aber die, wenn man es schafft, sie zusammenzusehen. Also das klingt vielleicht missverständlich. Das muss ja nicht auf Teufel kommen raus sein. Aber wenn man in der Lage ist, Ähnlichkeiten in komplett unterschiedlichen Sachen zu erkennen, dann ist man schon einen Schritt weiter im Prozess einer allgemeingültigen Erkenntnishaftigkeit.
Du sagst, der Zustand der Paranoia wird erreicht, wenn plötzlich alles, was man wahrnimmt, zueinander passt.
Ja, das ist so ein Paradigma. Das kann man so ganz allgemein dahinsagen. Das haben verschiedene Leute in unterschiedlichen Ausformen gesagt, aber es trifft ja auch. Das ist eine sehr schöne, einleuchtende Erklärung für Paranoia, aber auch für den Zustand, den man erreicht, wenn alles, was man weiß, zusammenpasst.
Ein anderer schöner Punkt, wo sich die Paranoia immer wunderbar dran manifestiert, ist der Moment, wenn die schwarzen Hubschrauber auf dem Horizont auftauchen.
Ganz hervorragendes Beispiel, Tim, ganz hervorragendes Beispiel, die schwarzen Hubschrauber. Die schwarzen Hubschrauber, ich meine, das ist jetzt, wir springen jetzt ja schon mitten in ein ansonsten wirklich, wirklich komplexes Thema rein. Also die schwarzen Hubschrauber sind ja schon der dunkle Kern im Mysterium des Hubschraubers, mit dem wir uns massiv heute Abend vielleicht beschäftigen werden. Mal sehen, wo wir da überhaupt landen. Der schwarze Hubschrauber als Ausdruck der totalen Paranoia, des paradox konformen, aber auch gleichzeitig rebellischen Individuums, was irgendwo dazugehören will, aber gleichzeitig nur es selbst sein, wie man es halt beispielsweise in den US-amerikanischen Milizen findet, wo halt eine Erklärung her muss für eine als übermächtig empfundene Bedrohung. Für diese als übermächtig empfundene Bedrohung ist halt der schwarze Hubschrauber ein perfektes Schiffre. Als solches unterscheidet es sich überhaupt nicht oder eher der schwarze Hubschrauber oder es ist das Schiffre von dem schwarzen Mann, also tatsächlich dem schwarzen Mann aus dem Kinderlied, aber auch den schwarzen Männern in unmarkierten Regierungslimousinen, die Wilhelm Reich abtransportieren oder auch nicht den schwarzen Wesen, die am Türpfosten lauern, den Wächtern an der Schwelle, die man so herrlich gerne in den Gedankenwerten der Schizophrenen findet. Das Schwarze, das Unbekannte, dieses Wesen, auch natürlich das UFO. Wir latten hier sofort und ohne Pause rein in diese UFO-Bereiche. Der schwarze Hubschrauber ist immer dort, wo die UFOs auftauchen. Wo die UFOs auftauchen, ist auch der schwarze Hubschrauber. Der schwarze Hubschrauber ist da, wo die FIFA-Stümmelungen stattfinden. Der schwarze Hubschrauber ist eigentlich inzwischen schon ein komplett unsichtbarer Hubschrauber und nicht mehr schwarz. Denn natürlich kommt dieser schwarze Hubschrauber noch aus der analogen Zeit. Er ist eine Figur aus den 80ern. Inzwischen hat es zu einer universellen Mythologie geronnen. In Wirklichkeit, was hören wir heute?
Das Internet ist der schwarze Hubschrauber des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Das Internet ist der schwarze Hubschrauber des 21. Jahrhunderts. Und er ist auch das UFO des 21. Jahrhunderts. Und es ist auch die schwarze Kreatur auf der Schwelle des 21. Jahrhunderts. Beziehungsweise jetzt schon auf der Schwelle zum 22. Jahrhundert.
Weil das alles böse in sich vereinigt.
Genau.
Und deswegen ist unser Innenminister so sehr hinterher.
Und es ist ja gar nicht so sehr ein konkretes Böses. Das ist ja das Problem mit diesen geistigen Bereichen. Also den Abweichungen, den Glaubenswelten, den abweichenden Glaubenswelten von Paranoikern, von Schizoiden, von Soziopathen, dass das Böse, was sie evozieren, was sie auch als gegen sich selbst gerichtet fühlen, häufig wenig konkret ist. Wobei, da man selbstverständlich jetzt auch diese Aussage disputabel, aber man kann natürlich sagen, wer will schon mit einem Paranoiker? Das ist ja der alte Spruch nicht wahr. Du bist doch selber Diskordia. Du kennst doch diese ganzen Paradigma.
Ich weiß nicht, auf welches du hinausmüsst.
Dass einer der Paranoid ist und denkt, jeder ist hinter ihm her und keiner will, was mit ihm zu tun haben, durchaus recht hat. Weil wer will schon, was mit einem Paranoiker zu tun hat?
Nur weil ich Paranoid bin, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass sie nicht auch hinter mir her sind. Den schwarzen Hubschrauber gab es, da fällt mir gerade so ein, da gab es auch so eine, kennst du bestimmt, so eine amerikanische Fernsehserie, in der... Der schwarze Hubschrauber. Nee, hieß nicht so, ich komme jetzt aber gerade leider nicht auf den Namen.
Ich denke, du sprichst hier von Airwolf.
Ah ja, genau, Airwolf, das war es. Das war ja auch so der prototypische, immer das modernste an Technik und ich weiß nicht, was er alles konnte, war wie im Radar nicht zu sehen und Pipapo und Latteflechten und so.
Ah, der war wunderbar.
Sah auch sehr schick aus. Das hast du bestimmt geguckt, von vorne bis hinten.
Ja, also ich hab mir die Schlusslese... Also man muss wissen, dass der Airwolf ja eigentlich als Fernsehserie, den die meisten Leute kennen, eine Art Fortsetzung eines Films war. Der originale Airwolf war ja ein abendführender Spielfilm. Und es gab zu dem Zeitpunkt, als diese Filme entstanden, auch mehrere der gleichen Art. Zum Beispiel gehört dieser Film Blue Thunder auch dazu. Es war sozusagen eine Art mediale Vorweg-Channelung der Technologie, die als nächstes kommen wird. Der Airwolf war natürlich eine Art prominenter Vertreter. Und zwar gleich aus mehreren Gründen. Erstens war er verfasst. Dort, wo das klassische Unbekannte die fliegenden Drachen und die UFOs und natürlich die schwarzen Helikopter selbst immer verfasst waren. Paradoxerweise zugleich in der Luft, abgehoben von den Menschen, aber auch unterirdisch. Der Airwolf stieg immer aus einem Vulkan aus, einer Art Geheimorganisation unterhielt diese ganze Anlage. Und der Airwolf am Steuer der Boy-Schauspieler Jan-Michel Vincent, der davor nie bekannt gewesen war, nur mit irgendwelchen Teenie-Klamotten rettete in jeder Folge erneut die Welt. Dass der Schwarze Hubschrauber dort ein guter Schwarzer Hubschrauber war, hatte natürlich viel mit den Programmen zu tun, die man verkaufen wollte. Nämlich diese neue Technologie in der Überwachung der Städte, überhaupt Sicherheitstechnologie. Das sollte alles als positiv dargestellt werden. Und auf einer bildsprachlichen Ebene wurde das auch signifiziert, indem der schwarze Hubschrauber in Airwolf nicht komplett schwarz war, sondern ganz interessanterweise so ein Farbmuster von so einem Orkerwal hatte. Der hatte einen weißen Bauch, womit er eigentlich gut war und als verletzlich gekennzeichnet. Der fliegende, fliegende, ja, eigentlich eine fliegende untersiege Kreatur auch. Hier kommen wir wieder an diesem Zusammensehen dessen, was eigentlich nicht zusammengehört. Das ist wiederkehrendes Dilemma, wenn man sich in diesen Bereichen bewegt oder mit diesen ganzen Fragen beschäftigt. Die Dinge sind nicht so klar geschieden. Es ist nie entweder oder. Es ist häufig sowohl als auch. Wenn man das gerade mit solchen Problemen zu tun hat, ist, wir kommen zurück auf die von mir eingangs vielleicht etwas ungeschickt beschriebene Technik des Zusammensehens. Wenn man sich in solchen Gegenden bewegt, wo die Dinge nicht so klar geschieden sind, dann kann es durchaus von Vorteil sein, dass man einen Sinn entwickelt, um die Unterschiede oder die Gegensätze auch tatsächlich zusammenzusehen.
Ich denke nach. Welche Gegensätze meinst du jetzt?
Irgendwelche Gegensätze. Die Assoziation des Disparaten. Du sprachst am Anfang darauf an, die Eratik als eine Technik des Zusammenschauens von Dingen, die nicht eigentlich zusammengehören.
Also Blue Sunner hast du erwähnt, ist ja hier bekannt unter dem Namen das fliegende Auge.
Das fliegende Auge, genau. Die Idee dieser umspannenden Überwachung. Damals hat noch keiner an GPS oder hier Google Earth oder solche Sachen gedacht. Dort war es halt immer noch eine einzelne Körperschaft, die dann herangeflogen werden muss. Und das ist halt auch eine Technik, die schon seit Anfang der 80er entwickelt wurde. Und zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieser Filme unmittelbar vor der Veröffentlichung stand. Das war eine Zeit, in der man sich halt auch zum Beispiel in Los Angeles, da so ein ziemlicher Punkt Bluthunder spielt, auch in Los Angeles. Und in Los Angeles hat man diese Technik auch perfektioniert. Also die Polizeihubschrauber und dort hatten, was dort ausprobiert war, war eigentlich die Schule oder die Erkenntnis, die man dort gewann, wurden halt auf der ganzen Welt angewendet. Schließlich natürlich auch bei uns mit den neuen Messerschmitthubschraubern. Also alle Fehler, die man da unten gemacht hat, hat man hier quasi versucht zu vermeiden oder durch Technik zu überkommen.
Technische Fehler meinst du jetzt?
Nein, überhaupt. Was heißt Fehler? Ich meine, manche Sachen sind Fehler. Klar, vielleicht waren es keine Fehler. Vielleicht wusste man nur einfach nicht genau, was man tat und musste halt ausprobieren, was man machen konnte. Was man tatsächlich mit dieser, also als Beispiel, um beim Hubschrauber zu bleiben. Ja, ein Beispiel. Bis, naja, tatsächlich noch bis Mitte der 90er wurden Luftaufnahmen, egal ob für irgendwelche Spielfilme, Nachrichten, Hawaii-Werbung, gemacht, indem man einen Kameramann in der offenen Tür eines Hubschraubers anschneidet, der eine Kamera auf der Schulter hat, und dann flog man rum. Und so wurden diese Aufnahmen gewonnen. Nicht, dass jetzt der Hubschrauber eine neue Technologie wäre. Aber es hat trotzdem immer noch zehn Jahre gedauert, bis man angefangen hat, tatsächlich hochwertige Systeme, also zu entwickeln, in denen der Hubschrauber sich in die Kamera verwandelte. Sicherlich hat damit auch die weitere technische Entwicklung zu tun. Computer, du weißt schon, all dieses Zeug. Die Sachen wurden immer leichter, immer stabiler. Also konnte man auch immer bessere Geräte entwickeln. Aber erst vor ca. 10 Jahren haben die großen Nachrichtencenter aufgehört, ihre Kameraleute in die Tür von Hubschraubern zu setzen und hatten halt einfach mal ausgerüstete Maschinen.
Ja, jetzt nutzt man Drohnen.
Und jetzt nutzt man Drohnen und braucht nicht mal mehr die Leute, die diese Teile rumfliegen, korrekt.
Also was ja auch jetzt schon zur Sprache gekommen ist, Hubschrauber sind immer nicht ausschließlich, aber dann doch wirklich auch primär, denke ich, gibt es immer so diese Assoziationen. Das sind Überwachungsgeräte, das sind so universale Rettungsteile. Das benutzt die Polizei, das benutzt das Militär. Also gerade dieses militärische Bild des Hubschraubers ist ja extrem geprägt. Ich würde sagen, also das Erste, was einem immer so in den Sinn kommt, ist so diese Vietnam-Bilder, wo die Amerikaner mit Massen an Hubschraubern im Einsatz waren. Ich weiß nicht, ob das der ausuferndste Einsatz von Hubschraubern im Krieg überhaupt war. Weißt du das?
Das war, ja doch, man kann das schon sagen. Also in dem Ausmaß hat es ja sowieso bisher, ich weiß nicht, ich habe zwar jetzt nicht die Zahlen im Kopf, die der Vietnamkrieg insgesamt gekostet hat und kann sie deshalb auch nicht gegen die Zahlen im Irak vergleichen, aber Vietnam war nicht nur der erste Hubschrauberkrieg, weil die Technik dort angewendet werden konnte, sondern bis dato halt auch der aufwändigste als Hubschrauberkrieg geführte, denn alle Doktrinen sind dort erst einmal entwickelt worden. Jetzt zum Beispiel auf aktuellen Kriegsschauplätzen ist das halt seit dem ersten Afghanistankrieg oder seit dem Russisch, nicht dem ersten Afghanistankrieg, was bedeutet das denn? Seit dem Krieg der Afghanen gegen die Russen in den 80er-Jahren, dort kamen halt die Wände mit den amerikanischen Raketen. Bis dahin waren die Hubschrauber relativ sicher. Inzwischen sind die Hubschrauber nicht mehr relativ sicher.
Und dann kamen diese Anti-Aircraft-Missiles, die man auf die Schulter banden konnte.
Und dass die Hubschrauber zum Beispiel nicht das Bild des Krieges im Irak bestimmen, sondern so haben, wie es die von AEDs in die Luft geblasen werden, das hat schon auch was damit zu tun. Ich stimme dir dazu, der Vietnamkrieg, das war der erste Krieg, der zugleich ein medialer Krieg war, weil es wurde permanent darüber berichtet, die Journalisten waren überall mit dabei, und es gab eine unglaubliche Bilderproduktion. Aber die Bilder wurden bestimmt vom Bild der neuen Technologie, die es zuvor in den Kriegen noch nicht gegeben hat, nämlich der Hubschrauber.
Stimmt das eigentlich, dass die Hubschrauber, die da im Einsatz waren, so bewusst auf laut gemacht waren?
Nein, die Hubschrauber waren besonders laut, aber das war jetzt eine Spezifik dieses speziellen Modells, der Bell UH-1D, das war der klassische Hubschrauber, der, später wurde das halt so zu Yui verballhornt, eine Spezifik dieser Hubschrauber war, dass das zurückkehrende Rotorblatt eigentlich kurzzeitig mit Übergeschallgeschwindigkeit unterwegs war und darum knallte. Und das machte diesen Hubschrauber besonders laut.
Gut, dann sind wir jetzt vielleicht nach diesem kulturellen Einstieg in das Thema, vielleicht auch nochmal an dem unvermeidlichen Technik-Thema angekommen.
Sprechen wir jetzt über Geld?
Nein, jetzt reden wir über das Geld, was ich hier gerade beiseite lege, das lege ich einfach nur ein bisschen beiseite. Ja, ab und zu muss man auch mal ein bisschen Geld beiseite legen. Du weißt, wie das ist. Die Hörer sind jetzt verwirrt, die können überhaupt nicht sehen, was wir hier machen. Das ist nicht Film, das ist Radio.
Genau, ich vergesse das auch immer wieder.
Wir steigen aus dem Äther auf wie ein Hubschrauber aus dem Wald. Ja, fast lautlos. Aber die Technik. Was macht denn ein Hubschrauber zu einem Hubschrauber? Also was ist jetzt sozusagen das Spezifikum, wo man sagen kann, das ist jetzt ein Hubschrauber und da hört es auf, ein Hubschrauber zu sein, weil diese und jene Bedingungen es nicht erfüllt. Was macht technisch einen Hubschrauber aus? Wir wissen alle, da dreht sich was, aber was macht das Ding? Was bringt das Ding zum Fliegen?
Das ist ja großartig. Liebe Kinder, ich hoffe, ihr hört jetzt alle gut zu, weil der Onkel Rosa erklärt jetzt den Unterschied zwischen einem Drehflügel.
Chaosradio Express ist Sendung mit der Maus für ausgebackst.
Ja, also was macht einen Hubschrauber aus? Naja, ich würde sagen, dass er in der Lage ist, durch eigene Kraft aus dem Stand nach oben aufzusteigen und in der Luft stehen zu bleiben. Und zwar ohne, dass er sich zu diesem Startbehufe nach vorne bewegen muss, um quasi wie ein Flugzeug Fahrt aufzunehmen, um den Druck bzw. Unterdruck an den Tragflächen zu erzeugen. Weil diesen für den Auftrieb nötigen Druck erzeugt er durch das irrsinnig schnelle Drehen seiner Hubschraube. Und das macht ihn zum Hubschrauber.
Und das Rotieren ist natürlich auch wichtig, weil es gibt ja auch diese Senkrechtsstarter, die machen irgendwie...
Die Senkrechtsstarter? Genau, genau. Aber die machen es ja nicht mit einer Hubschraube. Und sind darum auch keine Hubschrauber.
Also es muss sich schon was schrauben.
Es muss sich was schrauben. Meistens oben an dem Gerät, es gibt natürlich auch welche, wo es unten angebracht ist, so experimentelle Modelle. Es gibt aber auch welche, wo es halt an der Seite angebracht ist. Und der Pilot sitzt dazwischen. Es gibt überhaupt ganz viele unterschiedliche eigentliche Hubschrauber-Modelle. Leider sind wir ja bloß im Radio. Ich müsste also anfangen, die detailliert zu beschreiben.
Man muss einfach nur blumig genug ausmachen.
Also es gibt da welche, die sehen aus wie fette Hummeln. Und es gibt welche, die sehen aus wie Grashüpfer oder Libellen. Und das in unglaublich unterschiedlichen Größen. Der kleinste, der würde hier in dieses Zimmer reingehen, von dem ich sage, es ist mal so vier mal fünf Meter. Da würde der kleinste ungefähr reingehen. Und der Große, naja, der würde da drüben nicht mal in der Straße Platz finden.
Aber es gibt ja auch so ganz kleine Modelle.
Ach so, eine Modelle, natürlich. Du meintest so richtig die Nutzlast. Selbstverständlich gibt es Modelle, aber auf die trifft natürlich grundsätzlich die Beschreibung auch zu, dass sie so aus dem Stand nach oben aufkommen. Du meintest so richtig Nutzlast-Hubschrauber, ein Modell ist selbstverständlich auch ein Hubschrauber. Ich wollte die Kollegen vom Modellhubschrauberverein jetzt nicht dissen. Ich dachte, wir sprechen aber schon von richtigen Hubschraubern. Oder was sagen wir? Personen tragende Hubschrauber, nicht richtige Hubschrauber. Die anderen sind auch richtige Hubschrauber.
Okay, Personentragende Hubschrauber. Passt auf jeden Fall auch noch rein in das Zimmer, aber nicht mit seinem ganzen Rotor, oder?
Na, nicht mit seinem ganzen Rotor. Aber wenn man die anständig zusammenfaltet, passt das auch hier rein.
Und wie viel Blätter braucht ein Hubschrauber, um wirklich gut fliegen zu können?
Na, ich würde sagen, das kommt auf das Torsionssystem an. Also, ob der jetzt in einem Drehmoment freier ist, dann braucht er mindestens zwei. Oder ob er kein Drehmoment freier ist, dann braucht er mindestens vier. Also, da ist ja dann immer noch dieser kleine Heckrotor dran.
Okay, erklär mal das Grundprinzip. Also, was führt dazu, dass das Ding nicht einfach nur sich...
Na, das Problem ist, durch die Kraftübertragung auf die Hubschraube wird ja auch eine gegenläufige Kraft frei, die den Korpus oder die Karosserie, oder wie man es nennt, Fuselage des Hubschraubers in die drehrichtung der Hubschraube entgegengesetzte Richtung treibt.
Es könnte ja sein, dass sozusagen die Schraube einfach stehen bleibt und die Kabine dreht sich.
Genau, das kennt man aus dem Fred Feuerstein, bei den Simpsons kann man das sehr häufig sehen, wenn der Hubschrauber quasi kopfüber fällt, einfach auf dem sich eigentlich drehenden Rotor liegen bleibt und stattdessen dreht sich die Kabine wie verrückt. Das ist ja jetzt natürlich lustig und komikhaft dargestellt, aber in Wirklichkeit beschreibt es natürlich die Situationskräfte sehr gut. Um diese Bewegung auszubalancieren und eigentlich in der Lage zu sein, die Maschine zu kontrollieren und unter Zählgerichte zu fliegen, ist der geniale Igor Sikorsky darauf verfallen, einen kleineren Propeller am Heck anzubringen, der eben dieser Kraft entgegenwirkt. Dadurch wird das Gerät stabilisiert. Für diese Art von Hubschraubern braucht man mindestens zwei Hauptrotorblätter und zwei Heckrotorblätter. Die andere Sache, wo die Kraftübertragung wegfällt, weil sie direkt in der Schraube erzeugt wird, sind das rückstoßgetriebene Blätter. Da gibt es eine Technik, die heißt Reaktionsantrieb. Wasserstoffperoxid wird durch eine chemische Reaktion auf die genaue Temperaturzahl nicht erhitzt und tritt unter hohem Druck durch die Enden der Rotorblätter aus. Durch diese wird in Rotationen versetzt und den Hubschrauber nach oben hebt. Das ist eine ganz geniale Technik. Leider scheint es so, als ob man Wasserstoffperoxid nicht in ausreichendem Mengen bereitstellen kann, um es als Treibstoff für solche Maschinen zu brauchen. Diese Maschinen sind relativ unkompliziert zu fliegen. Der Antrieb ist relativ teuer. Die sind in England schon vor einigen Jahren so serienreif entwickelt worden.
Das heißt, die Achse wird nicht angetrieben?
Genau, der Rotor treibt sich selber an. Es ist wie ein Luftkreisel. Die Karosserie mit dem Passagier hängt unten dran durch ein äußerst ausgeklügeltes System. Das im Detail zu beschreiben.
Da braucht man trotzdem noch diesen Gegenrotor, oder?
Den braucht man nicht, weil es keine Kraftübertragung gibt. Ein ausgeklügeltes System kann durch Vorwärts- bzw. Seitwärtsneigung diesen sich selbst antreibenden Rotor dadurch das Gefährt lenken, indem man diesen Rotor kippt. Man kippt ihn nach vorne, er fliegt nach vorne. Man kippt ihn nach links, das Gerät fliegt nach links.
Und wann braucht man mehr als diese zwei Rotorblätter?
In dem Moment, das ist baureienspezifisch. Die Antwort auf die Frage, was man mindestens braucht, waren zwei Blätter. Man kann natürlich auch eine mit drei Blättern bauen und eine mit vier Blättern. Das hängt davon ab, welche Hubschrauber man bauen will. Es gibt ja auch so Lastwagen, die nur vier Räder haben, aber auch welche, die hinten zwei Mal zwei Räder und insgesamt sechs Räder haben und welche, die acht Räder haben. Das kommt darauf an, was man...
Gut, aber braucht man mehr Blätter, um mehr Tragkraft zu erzeugen?
Das ist ganz paradox, weil am Anfang der Hubschrauber-Forschung hat man festgestellt, dass der Auftrieb bei weniger Blättern höher ist. Aber selbstverständlich, mit mehr Energie braucht man auch mehr Blätter, um mehr Druck zu erzeugen. Und dadurch kann man natürlich größeren Auftrieb erlangen.
Also man macht nicht die Blätter größer, sondern man macht...
Das kommt immer darauf an. Die Systematiken lassen sich staff werden. Also größere Blätter bringen mehr Auftrieb, aber dafür brauchst du ja dann auch wieder eine andere Kontrolle.
Wie rum drehen sich die eigentlich?
Das ist ganz interessant. Die drehen sich alle rechtsrum, außer in Frankreich. Da drehen sie sich linksrum.
Rechtsrum, von wo aus gesehen? Wenn ich von oben auf den Hubschrauber draufgucke?
Man muss hier rechts und links eigentlich vergessen und sagen, im Uhrzeigersinn und gegen den Uhrzeigersinn.
Also wenn ich von oben draufgucke?
Wenn ich von oben draufgucke, drehen sie sich im Uhrzeigersinn, außer in Frankreich, dann gegen den Uhrzeigersinn.
Warum ausgerechnet in Frankreich?
Das war eine unglaubliche Geschichte, die ich jetzt ad hoc auch nicht... Also ich weiß weder den Namen dieses Typen noch... Es ging um eine Schraube, es ging um ein Gewinde. Die Franzosen hatten früher eine andere Gewinderichtung. Und als die Französisch, als ein deutscher Ingenieur nach Frankreich gekommen ist, nach dem Krieg, also ich spreche vom Zweiten Weltkrieg, da gab es dieses Problem mit den unterschiedlichen Gewinderichtungen und schließlich führte das dazu, dass die Maschine andersrum lief.
Okay, das ist nachvollziehbar. Das war sozusagen einfach, wie sie es leichter bauen konnten.
Wie sie es leichter bauen konnten. Ach du je, hier dreht sich alles andersrum.
Okay, aber das haben die Franzosen dann irgendwann doch wieder sein lassen?
Oder drehen sie sich immer noch andersrum? Nö, das ist ganz normal, bei den Franzosen ist das normal so.
Also auch wenn ich mir heute noch einen französischen Hubschrauber kaufe, dann dreht er irgendwie andersrum?
Da müsste ich jetzt erstmal nochmal in meinen Unterlagen nachgucken, ob das...
Heißt das nicht mittlerweile Eurocopter?
Ja, das ist ja die Sache. Natürlich drehen sich nicht die Eurocopter linksrum, wenn sie in Frankreich sind und rechtsrum oder beziehungsweise gegen oder mit dem Uhrzeigersinn. Aber das ist ja natürlich...
Linksdrehgebot, das wäre doch was für die Franzosen, oder?
Ich denke, heute drehen sich die alle in eine Richtung, aber es sind ja dann auch schon wieder gesamteuropäische Hubschrauber und nicht französische oder deutsche.
Aber auch der Sikorski hat sich schon im Uhrzeigersinn drehen lassen.
Der Sikorski hat sich im Uhrzeigersinn drehen lassen. Diese frühen deutschen Hubschrauber haben sich... Es gibt ja noch diese anderen Modelle, wenn nicht das jetzt noch... Also was sehr beeindruckend ist, was man auch aus Vietnam jetzt wieder nochmal anknüpfen kann, sind diese, diese mit den zwei großen Rotoren. Das ist nochmal eine weitere Anordnung, eine Tannen-Anordnung. Da gibt es zwei große Rotoren, die sich halt gegenläufig drehen. Das heißt, einer dreht sich im Uhrzeigersinn und einer gegen den Uhrzeigersinn. Und das ist eine weitere Möglichkeit, diese Torsionskräfte aus...
Das heißt, da sind sozusagen zwei Rotorenpärchen übereinander?
Nee, das gibt es auch. Das ist nochmal was anderes.
Was meintest du jetzt?
Also, die Anordnung sind mannigfaltig. Also, du kannst zwei Hauptrotore übereinander haben, die sich halt gegenläufig drehen. Das nennt man Koaxial, weil sie sich halt um die gleiche Achse drehen.
Oder auch deutsch-französische Freunde.
Oder du kannst sie halt voneinander versetzt, entweder seitlich zum Rumpf, das wäre lateral, oder vorne und hinten, das wäre auch lateral, aber ein anderes Lateral anordnen. Und wie heißt denn das seitlich, ihr Mensch? Ach je. Diese Sachen liegen schon so lange her. Inzwischen beschäftige ich mich mit so viel anderen interessanten Sachen da draußen, die völlig unbekannt sind.
Ja, aber du hast dich ja mit dem Hubschrauber-Thema schon ganz gut verheiratet.
Ganz gut verheiratet.
Ich habe es noch nicht erwähnt, aber ich tue das jetzt mal. Du hast ja, wie das sich gehört, für einen gut gebildeten Menschen in einem Thema auch ein Buch geschrieben. Das heißt Helikopter History.
Also ja, es heißt Helikopter History. Die englische Vokation des Wortes soll eigentlich nur mitgedacht werden, aber nicht ausgesprochen werden. Das heißt also Helikopter History. Man kann natürlich die History so denken als History, also als Geschichte, aber es geht halt auch um diese Aspekte, über die wir eingangs gesprochen haben. Der Hubschrauber als mehr als nur das technische Gerät der Rettung des Krieges und so weiter, sondern der Hubschrauber quasi als Idee in der Ideengeschichte. Oder was für eine Idee ist der Hubschrauber eigentlich und wer hatte sie? Und wie war seine Gestalt? Das ist tatsächlich die Gestalt dieser Idee. Ist das der Hubschrauber oder steckt da noch andere Sachen dahinter? All diese Gedanken und Spekulationen sollen sich spiegeln in diesem Titel Helikopter History. Die in 2008 hoffentlich endlich erscheinen werdende englische Ausgabe wird heißen Historia. Also mit Y, da werden noch ganz andere Wörter verschränkt. Das heißt dann Helikopter Historia, The.
Ist das noch eine Übersetzung oder ist das noch ein anderer Ansatz?
Ja, es ist eine Übersetzung der Hauptteile mit den üblichen Erweiterungen, die halt der tatsächlichen Entwicklung auf diesem Bereich geschuldet sind. Das Buch ist ja ein Fachbuch. Das heißt, ich muss immer beobachten, was dort geschieht, sonst veraltet das Buch irgendwann. Also die Entwicklungen auf dem Gebiet dieses Hubschrauberphänomens, wenn man das so nennen kann, bleiben ja nicht stehen. Und 2008 passieren da ganz andere Dinge als 2004. Und das will beobachtet werden. Und das will natürlich in Beziehung gesetzt werden zu allem, was es vorher gegeben hat. Insofern ist keine Neuerscheinung und auch jetzt nicht die englische Neuerscheinung genau das Gleiche als wie zuvor.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall kein technisches Buch, wo es irgendwie erklärt wird, wie man sich selber einen Hubschrauber baut, sondern es ist mehr so ein kultureller, also ein breitbandiger Blick auf die Kultur des Hubschraubers.
Absolut, wenn du so willst, eine Kulturgeschichte des Hubschraubers inklusive einer kohärenten Abhandlung seiner technischen Spezifikation.
Alles, was sie über Hubschrauben schon immer wissen wollten.
Ja, das ist spannend. Ich habe hier die ESPN-Nummer mitgebracht, die du vorlesen kannst, wenn du möchtest.
Das ist schön, ich pack das einfach in die Links. Das Schreibt ihr jetzt sowieso nicht an. Wir sind ja hier in der Click-Welt. Da mach ich das immer so. Ich beschreibe immer alles, was wir hier erzählen. Das kommt dann hier irgendwie rein. Ich muss das jetzt mal erklären. Einerseits für die neuen Hörer, die soll es ja immer geben. Und auch für dich. Oh Heinrich, der du wahrscheinlich kein regelmäßiger Hörer von Chaosradio Express bist, sollst du aber sein. Ich mach die Links. Ich hör das alles nochmal ab, was wir hier zum Besten geben. Und dann kommt das in die Beschreibung. Und dann findet sich das in der MP3-Datei, in den Lyrics und auf der dazugehörigen Webseite. Auch schön zum Klicken. So auch der Verweis auf dein tolles Buch. Da gibts super Kapitel. Wolltest du was dazu sagen?
Ja, muss aber nicht sein. Ich komme vom analogen Luftradio. Da sind solche fortschrittlichen Sachen natürlich nicht möglich. Da wird eine Zahl einfach mal in die Luft reingesagt. Und draußen in Berlin kann man sie dann im Autoradio hören. Du musst das jetzt nicht deshalb machen. Das ist so eine Art Sache. Wenn man das im Autoradio hört, dann hört man es ja doch auch vom Pod, denke ich mal. Und kann es dann sogar 100-mal zurückspielen. Wenn es sein muss. Es ist also vollkommen überflüssig, das in die Luft rein zu sagen. Aber wie gesagt, ich komme vom analogen Luftradio. Da haben wir das immer mit großer Freude gemacht.
Hast du mal Radio gemacht?
Ja, ich habe Radio in Berlin gemacht. Ich bin einigen auch bekannt unter meinem geheimen DJ-Namen DJ-Officer. Da habe ich so häufig Radiosendungen gemacht zu nicht-mainstreamen kulturellen Themen.
Welches Radio?
Wie hießen denn diese Radios? Das waren diese Radios. Ich habe damals angefangen mit Radio 100. Radio 100. Dann gab es immer wieder Radioprojekte. Dann wurden diese Radioprojekte belohnt mit irgendwelchen Frequenzen. Sobald es diese Frequenzen gab, habe ich eine Sendung gemacht. Das ist mein erster Internetradio. Es ist ja nicht mal Internet, doch ist es Internet. Es ist nur Podcast.
Das widerspricht sich. Man könnte es theoretisch live hören.
Aber heute zufällig nicht. Alle, die das jetzt hören, hören es nicht live. So ist es. Das ist der Punkt. Nicht nur wollte ich die Besonderheit, dass Radio immer live gehört haben, sondern auch unaufgenommen quasi. Was am Schluss mit diesen Radio-Projekten nicht mehr funktionierte, weil die selbstverständlich luftmäßig ausgesendet wurden. Aber die Daten wurden trotzdem durch das Internet übertragen.
Das Luftradio hat das Problem, dass wenn auf der anderen Seite keiner sitzt, dann hat man einfach nur ins Leere gehustet. Das passiert uns hier Gott sei Dank nicht so leicht. Deswegen finde ich Podcast ganz toll. Aber es soll ja nicht um Podcast gehen oder um das Internet.
Oder das Luftradio.
Aber schon ein bisschen um die technische Entwicklung. Hubschrauber waren ja auch schon immer so ein bisschen der Ausdruck eines Traums. Sicherlich auch Flugzeuge. Das hängt dann immer so ein bisschen davon ab, wie man fragt. Wir hatten das ja schon eingangs so auch so mit dieser Allmacht und diesem irgendwie ich alleine und der Hubschrauber. So dieses Vor, Zurück und Hoch und Runter. Sich verstecken können. Unangekündigt mal so aus dem Nichts auftauchen und einfach so da zu sein. Das ist ja das, was Hubschrauber eigentlich immer so ausgemacht hat. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so eine begleitende Allmachts-Fantasie, die so dem Hubschrauber-Nörder sicherlich auch eine Rolle spielt, dass seine Faszination so ist, wie sie ist. War das bei dir auch so? Wie bist du denn zu Hubschraubern gekommen?
Wenn ich also jetzt diesen Gedankengang mit dem Hubschrauber-Nörd weiterspinnen sollte, müsste ich sagen, ich kam zu dem Hubschrauber, als ich Gott wurde. Oder als ich versuchte, Gott zu werden. Wie war das? Interessant. Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich das tun wollte, so war es ja nicht. In Wirklichkeit wurde es Gott, wenn man so will. Und ich traf eine Vorhersage in New York am Ostersonntag im Jahr 1991 in Anwesenheit von, was ich im halben Dutzend deutscher Touristen, darunter zwei meiner Freunde, und sagte, dieser nächste Hubschrauber, der hier lang fliegt, wird abstürzen. Und dann stürzte dieser Hubschrauber ab. Vor unseren Augen, ja. Und nicht nur passierte das, nein, es wurde dann auch im Fernsehen darüber berichtet, aber es kam noch besser. An dem Tag traf ich noch in Zusammenhang mit diesen Geschehnissen eine zweite Vorhersage. Das Gebäude wurde abgesperrt. Ich hatte mir das gedacht. Ich hatte mich irgendwie schon zuvor mit dieser Thematik ein wenig beschäftigt. Und ja, ich sagte, wir sollten hier rausgehen, dann können wir besser sehen. Der Hubschrauber trieb ja den Fluss runter. Ich dachte, wir machen ein paar Fotos und so. Kurz danach wurde das Gebäude abgesperrt, aber wir waren draußen, als die Fernsehteams eintrafen. Und meine zweite Vorhersage betraf sozusagen mich, der über die Vorhersage im Fernsehen spricht, in New York. Es war vollkommen absurd. Ich wusste also, bis diese Nachrichten nicht ausgestrahlt wurden, ob es tatsächlich eine Vorhersage war. Das kann man ja vorher nicht wissen. Dort war es aber so intensiv, mein Gefühl für diese Vorhersagenhaftigkeit auch bestätigt durch den Abschluss des Hubschraubers, dass ich tatsächlich im Fernsehen war und dann über diesen von mir vorhergesagten Hubschrauberabsturz geredet habe.
Du bist aber erst aufgenommen worden im Fernsehen, nachdem er abgestürzt ist. Aber nicht mit deiner ursprünglichen, leidauf-offenen Aussage, das haben nur Leute bestätigt.
Das waren ja nur meine permanent von da an komplett fassungslos bleibenden Kollegen.
Du warst mit einer Touristengruppe in New York, wo standet ihr?
Am East River, am Heliport an der 34. Straße. Es war eine total idiotische Touristensache. Wir wollten einen Rundflug über New York machen. Und das war alles voll mit Touristen, weil es war ja Oster Sonntag.
Und du warst der Touristenführer?
Nein, ich war nicht der Touristenführer. Ich war einer der Touristen mit meinen Freunden zwischen diesen anderen Touristen. Und das waren alles Deutsche.
Und dann kamen Hubschrauber und du hast gesagt...
Nein, wir standen nicht rum und es kamen Hubschrauber. Selbstverständlich standen wir in dem Heliport. Da waren zwei Hubschrauber, die ständig hin und herflogen. Weil das war ja der Heliport. Und wir warteten alle, von diesen Hubschraubern transportiert zu werden. Die Geschichte ist wirklich komplex. Soll ich die ganze Geschichte erzählen?
Das Internet hat genug Platz, wenn sie lustig ist.
Sie ist weniger lustig als total bis heute unfassbar. Wir standen da. Die Geschichte fing eigentlich 1987 in San Francisco an.
Ich wusste, dass ich mir dabei aufs Ei gefangen habe.
87 habe ich ein Foto in der Tageszeitung in San Francisco gesehen. Ich war zu der Zeit in San Francisco. Es zeigte einen abgestürzten Hubschrauber. Mit diesem Foto passierte etwas. Man kennt das aus der französischen Literatur. Coup de foudre. Man wird von irgendetwas geschlagen. Man kann sich nicht dagegen wehren. Eigentlich geht es da meistens um Verliebtheit. Man wird sofort von einem Objekt sein. Vom Blitz getroffen. Genau, verliebt wie vom Blitz getroffen. Mir passierte das jetzt. Zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste ich noch nicht, ob das gut ist oder schlecht. Oder was es überhaupt bedeutet. Das hat mich in erster Linie verwirrt. Das Foto des abgestürzten Hubschraubers hatte mich gebannt. Ich schnitt es aus. Ich trug es in meiner Hemmtasche mit mir rum. Ich zog es jeden Tag.
Ein abgestürzten oder abstürzten?
Ein abgestürzten. Der lag dort auf der Seite. Es war ein grobkörniges, schwarz-weiß gerastertes San-Francisco-Examiner-Foto. Es war nicht irgendein Foto. Durch dieses Foto verlängert sich die Geschichte noch weiter zurück bis 1982. Steven Spielberg hatte Twilight Zone neu verfilmt und auf die große Leinwand gebracht. Dabei gab es auch eine Vietnamkriegsgeschichte. Wir gehen jetzt direkt zurück an die Quelle der Vietnamkrieg. Steven Spielberg hatte eine Episode für Twilight Zone gedreht, in der der Hauptdarsteller, wie es in Twilight Zone eben so ist, mal eben woanders hin versetzt wird. Keiner weiß genau wo. Der war dann in Vietnam. Kurz und gut bei den Dreharbeiten stürzte der Hubschrauber ab und erschlug diesen Hauptdarsteller und die zwei vietnamesischen Kinder, die er auf dem Arm gehabt hatte. 1987 war endlich die Verhandlung zu Ende über den Schadenersatz. Und über diese Verhandlung wurde berichtet in San Francisco, in einem Examiner. Und als Bild zu dieser Geschichte war halt das Foto dieses abgestürzten Hubschraubers drin. Das ist jetzt sozusagen die Vor- oder Hintergrundgeschichte. Dieses Foto hat mich irgendwie getroffen. Und zwar der Gestalt, dass ich angefangen habe, damals in 1987 Hubschrauber zu fotografieren. Das konnte man einfach so. Ich wusste selber nicht warum. Es war kompulsiv eigentlich. Es hat aber auch Spaß gemacht. Ich beachtete plötzlich die Hubschrauber in einem vorher nicht existierenden Maße. Als wenn du so willst medienkünstlerhafte Geste, fing ich halt an, jeden vorbeifliegenden Hubschrauber irgendwie zu fotografieren. Wenn in einer Zeitung ein schönes Bild von einem Hubschrauber war, schnitt ich es halt aus, klebte es in so ein Album ein. Jetzt übertrieben. Ich habe es nur in so einem Umschlag getan. Aber in dieser Form. Das alles passierte und bedeutete auch weiter gar nichts. Ich lebte mein Leben ganz normal weiter. Popkultur, dergleichen Bücher lesen, Journalismus, bis, wie gesagt, 1991 New York. Wir sagten, wir fliegen. Und dann kam dieser unglaubliche Zwischenfall mit der Vorhersage. Der Hubschrauber stürzte tatsächlich ab. Ich fange jetzt da an. Wir gingen also runter. Das war Ostersonntag. Die Stadt war voll mit deutschen Touristen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Man konnte den Boardwalk nicht runtergehen, ohne nicht auf drei oder vier Leute, die man aus Berlin kannte, zu treffen. Und das muss man jetzt mal hochrechnen. Also auf ganz Deutschland. So war das ungefähr. 34. Straße, Heliport, Rundflüge. Zwei Hubschrauber im Einsatz. Schönes altes Modell. Noch das Urmodell damals in 54 eingesetzt, bekannt geworden durch den Koreakrieg. Dann an die Briten lizenziert und bis heute eigentlich im Einsatz immer wieder erneuert und aufgepeppt. Hier ist das bekannt als Westland Wessex. Die meisten werden das kennen als einen der Hubschrauber, die in Hamburg bei der Flut eingesetzt wurden. Also als in der Bundesrepublik bekanntes Medienbild. Und der andere war ein ganz normaler Jet Ranger, was man so kennt aus Airwolf, wenn die Bösen in einem Geschäfts-Hubschrauber unterwegs sind. Das waren diese beiden Hubschrauber. Wir standen da, es waren so viele Leute präsent. Und es war klar, dass es über eine Stunde dauert, bis wir dran sein würden. Und wir haben es uns halt bequem gemacht, haben was getrunken und uns unterhalten. Über was haben wir geredet? Über Hubschrauber. Und wenn man über Hubschrauber redet, ist naheliegend auch eigentlich... Ja, sagte der eine Typ dann, das... Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der heißt, das war der Freund meiner Freundin. Und die hatten sich gerade erst neu kennengelernt. Und er sagte so, ja, aber was wäre denn, wenn wir jetzt abstürzen? Und das war der Moment, wo ich so... Ja, man kann das höchstens mit einer Drogenerfahrung vergleichen. Ich fühlte mich irgendwie elektrisiert, auch in einen anderen Bewusstseinszustand hineinversetzt. Ich wusste gar nicht, was los ist. Auf jeden Fall sagte ich so, mich selber erschreckend eigentlich über die Überzeugung, mit der ich das vorbrachte, dass wir zwar nicht abstürzen würden, dass aber auf jeden Fall einer der Hubschrauber abstürzen würde. Das war dann genau... Also eine Seitenlinie ist jetzt noch, dass wir darüber gestritten haben, in welchem Hubschrauber wir denn fliegen wollten. Die beiden wollten in diesem Jetranger fliegen. Ich wollte aber in diesem alten Modell fliegen, weil ich mir irgendwie dachte, in einem Jetranger kann man immer noch fliegen, noch in zehn Jahren. Aber diese Dinger werden irgendwann verschwinden. Ich wollte unbedingt in dem fliegen. Was dann passierte, war halt, wie es aussah, würde ich meinen Wunsch nicht bekommen. Wir waren dann irgendwann dran. Wir und noch zwei andere Leute aus der Gruppe, also oder aus der Schlange, wurden halt vorgebeten, durch die Schleuse gebracht, auf das Flugfeld hinaus begleitet. Und dann stürze der, der gleich landen sollte, der dann unser gewesen wäre, stürze vor unseren Augen einfach in den Fluss. Das wäre jetzt auch nicht...
Das wäre jetzt ein Jet Ranger gewesen.
Das wäre der Jet Ranger gewesen. Der Jet Ranger ist da reingefallen. Das ist jetzt auch kein so dramatischer Absturz gewesen. Man hört ja von diesen Hubschrauber-Abstürzen am Heliport von der 34. Straße häufiger. Alle zwei Jahre oder so kommt da so ein Ding runter. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so ungewöhnlich. Aber es war halt doch schon sehr ungewöhnlich und präzise, dass es einfach der war, mit dem wir fliegen sollten, und der vor unseren Augen abstürze. Das heißt, wir hatten den Absturz tatsächlich nur um so, weiß ich, fünf Leute, fünf Zähler verpasst. Und dadurch flogen wir natürlich in den anderen. Aber das ändert ja nichts daran, dass wir sozusagen nicht selber in diesem Hubschrauber gewesen sind. Weil ich hatte es ja absurderweise vorhergesagt.
Und dadurch wart ihr dann in dem Alten.
Und dadurch waren wir dann in dem Alten. Aber ich will jetzt auf keinen Fall sozusagen ein Reasoning erzeugen, das dazu führt, dass du mein... Das ist absurd. Das ist ganz absurd. Die Geschichte muss man sehr trocken betrachten. Ich übertreibe die auch nicht. Im Gegenteil, also man neigt ja dazu, im Laufe der Jahre Geschichten auszuschmücken. Bei dieser Geschichte habe ich immer sehr darauf geachtet, nicht anzufangen, das auszuschmücken, sondern im Gegenteil es auf die eigentliche Geschichte zu reduzieren, gerade um dieser Gefahr vorzubeugen. Es handelt sich nämlich um eine wahre Geschichte. Jahre später, als ich mit dem Buch auf Vortragsreise war, war ich in Frankfurt. Die Frau, die inzwischen verheiratet war und gar nicht mehr so hieß, als sie mit diesem Hubschrauber abstürzte, war auch in der Sendung gewesen. Da hat New York im Fernsehen eine Berichterstattung darüber gegeben. Es gab einen ca. 3 Minuten langen Beitrag. Die Frau wurde auch interviewt, die in dem Hubschrauber gesessen hat. Ich erinnere mich noch genau, was sie gesagt hat. Sie sagte auf dem Sender so, I felt nothing, I felt fine, for me it was fun. The crash was actually more fun than the ride. Das hat sie gesagt und diese Worte habe ich nie verlassen.
Das heißt, sie haben alle überlebt?
Es gab überhaupt nicht mal Verletzte. Diese Vorrichtungen haben einwandfrei funktioniert. Pantons an den Kufen bliesen sich auf. Das Ding war etwas hart, aber ohne zu zerbrechen. Es landete auf der Wasseroberfläche. Es war ja sowieso nicht mehr so hoch.
Es gibt so etwas wie ein Airbag für Hubschrauber.
Es gibt mittlerweile richtige Airbags für Hubschrauber. Im Innenraum gibt es für Notwasserungen, wenn der Hubschrauber ausgerüstet ist, aufblasbare Schwimmer an der Unterseite.
Es gibt eine Nottaste, die man drücken muss.
Das ist nur, damit der Hubschrauber im Wasser nicht untergeht. Man kann auch relativ sicher, es kommt auf die Höhe an die Windverhältnisse und die Qualifikation des Piloten, mit einem gewöhnlichen Hubschrauber eine Notlandung machen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Also, wie gesagt, wenn die Umstände günstig stehen. Weil der Hubschrauber sich ja in Bewegung befindet. Und der Rotor sich dreht. Und der Rotor wird sich auch weiter drehen, wenn jetzt nicht irgendwas dazwischenkommt, wie ein Stromkabel oder eine Drachenschnur oder irgendwas sonst. Solange der Rotor sich dreht und der Hubschrauber fahrt, behält, kann er einfach landen. Das nennt man Autorotation.
Das ist interessant, weil ich denke, das ist immer das, was viele Leute sich so fragen, generell in der Aviation. Also auch ich selber war da eher so ein bisschen rosenscheißerisch draus. Hab mich auch in Flugzeugen nicht so wohl gefühlt. Nicht, dass ich total paranoid war. Aber für den Moment einer Panne hatte ich das rechte Vertrauen nicht in Flugzeuge. Bis ich dann irgendwann mal in so einer kleinen Nuckelpinne beim Freund mitgeflogen bin. Und der so wie Albatross Airlines bei Bernhard und Bianca heute die Polter über so eine Hucke Wald- und Wiesenpiste gestartet und später dann auch gelandet ist, wo ich nicht im Traum darüber nachgedacht hätte, dass sowas überhaupt zugelassen wäre, dass man da ein Fahrzeug rüberlässt. Aber das hat diesem Gerät eine herzliche wenig ausgemacht. Da habe ich dann auch wirklich mal sehr live gespielt. Das war so eine kleine Zweisitzer-Chessner. Was für eine Eigenstabilisation, Eigenstabilisationskraft so ein Flugzeug überhaupt hat. Also da gehört schon einiges dazu, das überhaupt erst mal aus der Spur zu bringen. Wenn man das jetzt mal überträgt auf den Hubschrauber, da hat man ja immer so dieses Gefühl, ich finde jetzt, ich glaube, dass das allgemeine Glauben so ist, da geht der Sprit alle und dann fällt das Ding einfach auf den Boden. Jetzt sagst du, der schraubt einfach weiter als wäre nichts.
Was passiert denn, wenn der Sprit alle ist? Natürlich, wenn der Sprit alle ist, muss der Pilot so schnell wie möglich landen. Er hat halt ein gewisses Zeitfenster und das ist etwa so groß, wie er in der Lage ist, den Hubschrauber im Vorwärtsflug zu behalten. Solange der Hubschrauber sich mit einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit im Vorwärtsflug bewegt, drehen sich, wie gesagt, die Rotorblätter. Und erzeugen Auftrieb.
Der muss vorwärts fliegen?
Ja, wenn aus irgendeinem Grund der Rotor stoppt, oder ein Teil abbricht, dann stürzt ein Hubschrauber ab. Aber das Gleiche passiert beim Flugzeug, wenn der Flügel abbricht. So lange das Gerät intakt ist, gibt es im Hubschrauber ganz normal, wie bei einem Flugzeug auch die Möglichkeit, notzulernen. Das ist genau das Gleiche. Wie lange drehen sich diese Rotorblätter? Ich muss noch mal sagen, die Prinzipien des Auftriebs sind beim Hubschrauber und beim Flugzeug nicht verstanden. Nur die Technik, mit der dieser Auftrieb erreicht wird, ist unterschiedlich.
Aus diesem Grund sind die Rotorblätter auch genauso geformt wie Flugzeugflügel?
Ja, die Entwicklung ist inzwischen so spezifisch, dass man das immer weiter verfeinert hat. Aber grundsätzlich kann man sagen, ja.
Aber es geht grundsätzlich durch die...
Die Oberfläche ist länger als die untere Fläche und die strömende Luft erzeugt dadurch oben langsamer und unten schneller und erzeugt dadurch Auftrieb. Das ist das gleiche Prinzip. Im Prinzip sind die Blätter der Hubschraube beim Hubschrauber das, was die Flügel an einem Flugzeug sind. Die Bewegung beim Flugzeug wird durch den Vortrieb erzeugt, entweder durch Jets oder einen Propeller. Beim Hubschrauber drehen sich die Blätter selber. Das ist der einzige Unterschied. Drehflügler sagt man ja auch.
Rotor. Gut, aber jetzt hast du ja gesagt, solange der Hubschrauber noch nach vorne fliegt.
Genau, wenn er gegen die Wand fliegt, hören die Blätter sich auch zu.
Aber angenommen, er steht. Hubschrauber können ja auch stehen.
In der Luft.
Genau. Jetzt ist der Sprit alle.
Was passiert? Dann muss er halt in den Vorwärtssturzflug. Das ist ja auch nach vorne.
Aber warum muss er denn nach vorne?
Um Bewegung aufzunehmen, um die Blätter anzutreiben.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo er sich nach vorne kippen würde, dann würden die Blätter, warum werden die dann angetrieben?
Eine Windmühle wird ja auch angetrieben vom Wind.
Dann würde es ja auch reichen, wenn der Hubschrauber von oben nach unten fliegt.
Das kann er unter gewissen Umständen natürlich auch machen, solange sich die Blätter noch drehen und wenn er nicht zu hoch ist.
Ja gut, ich meine, der Moment, wo der Sprit alle ist, da drehen sie sicher noch.
Ja, das ist nicht so einfach. Schau, wenn du auf einer Stelle bist, dann erzeugst du der Druck nach unten. Das heißt, wenn du in diesen Druck reinfliegst, gibt es Verwirbelungen, die wieder messen mit deinem Problem der Rotation. Das willst du nicht. Also willst du von dem Druck, den du hinter dir erzeugt hast, weg. Das heißt, du wirst versuchen, in einen vorwärts-sinkflug zu gehen, um eine Stelle zu finden, wo du runter setzen kannst.
Wie kann das der Pilot an der Stelle dann tun? Der muss dich dann irgendwie kippen, oder was?
Das macht er anhand der Ausbildung, die er genossen hat als Flugstrauepilot.
Aber welche Einflussnahme hat denn ein Pilot überhaupt?
Er kann alle möglichen Sachen machen.
Na was denn?
Ich bin kein Pilot. Ich kann nur sagen, was für Sachen der Pilot machen kann. Also es ist halt genau zu wissen, dass das möglich ist und wie es prinzipiell funktioniert, ist mein Wert entfernt von in der Lage zu sein, das durchzuführen. Also der Pilot kann den gesamten Neigungswinkel der gedachten ideellen Drehfläche des Rotors einstellen. Das heißt, er kann den gesamten Rotorkreis kippen, nach vorne. Er kann aber auch die einzelnen Rotorblätter kippen. Und er kann auch die Heckrotorblätter kippen.
Alle gleichzeitig oder die auch noch einzeln?
Das heißt, er kann das beides machen. Das gibt es eine zyklische Steuerung, dynamische Steuerung. Das sind unglaublich komplexe Technologien, die sich vereinigen auf dem Rotorkopf. Er hat halt mehrere Hebel. Er kann die Anstellwinkel verändern. Er kann verschiedene Winkel verändern, basically. Mathematik, wenn du so willst.
Aber es geht im Wesentlichen um Winkel?
Es geht im Wesentlichen um Winkel, genau. Und Kraft.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo der Sprit ausgeht, weiß er, ich muss weg von meinem Druck.
Ich will nicht in meine eigenen Werbe reinfallen. Ich will Fahrt aufnehmen.
Das heißt, er würde dann die Winkel, und jetzt wissen wir nicht genau, welche und wie, weil das hängt von tausend Sachen ab, auf jeden Fall beeinflusst er die Winkel von was auch immer, und dann kippt das Teil im Idealfall so leicht nach vorne und fliegt so schräg nach unten.
Von was auch immer nicht. Er beeinflusst die Winkel seiner Rotorblätter. Und zwar in einer dergestalt, dass sie den Fahrtwind annehmen können und dadurch in Drehung gehalten bleiben. In Drehung gehalten werden oder in Drehung bleiben.
Das heißt, das Ding ist dann auch schon, also das bläst dann sozusagen von unten in die Blätter rein. Nein? Nein, nein.
Der Fahrtwind.
Ja, aber der kommt doch von vorne.
Ja, eben. Und er bläst gegen den Hauptrotor, der sich weiterdreht und dadurch Auftrieb erzeugt.
Ja, aber der Wind bläst doch sowohl links als auch rechts von der Achse.
Ja, das Ding läuft nun mal in diese Richtung. Das ist natürlich ein gewisser Verlust. Deswegen solltest du halt auch schauen, dass du schnell irgendwo...
Okay, ich versuche es ja nur zu verstehen, weil das ist...
Also pass auf, ich habe es schon gesagt, Windmühle. Wenn du jetzt die Windmühle hier, dann ist dein Sohn es hast, du kannst von vorne dagegen pusten und sie wird sich drehen. Aber du kannst auch von der Seite dagegen pusten und sie wird sich auch drehen. Okay, das ist jetzt...
Da müsste man mal ausprobieren.
Ja, das kannst du machen, funktioniert.
Die Hörer sind schon dabei. Die haben jetzt alle ihre Windmühle, die sie natürlich im Regal stehen haben, rausgeholt und probieren das aus. Dann werden sie uns in den Kommentaren berichten.
Was auch interessant ist, ist zum Beispiel, dass, obwohl die gleichen Kräfte eigentlich angewendet werden, bei kleinen, also bei Modellhubschraubern, andere Regeln anwendbar sind als bei großen Hubschraubern. Weil, ich weiß nicht, wie kann man einen Modellhubschrauber überhaupt landen? Also einen Modellhubschrauber schon, aber diese kleinen Irrsinnmodelle? Ich weiß es nicht. Kann man da so eine Art Autorotation generieren?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich habe vor kurzem ein Video gesehen von so einem Modellhubschrauber. Es gibt da ja auch so diese Modellhubschrauber oder Modellflug-Community-RC-Movies. Da gibt es ganz viel absurdes Zeug. Irgendwie so dieser, was weiß ich, was für ein Meister, deutscher Meister, keine Ahnung, welchen Titel hat er sich abgeholt? Auf jeden Fall der hatte da irgendwie einen Hubschrauber am Start. Das ging irgendwie gar nicht mehr. Der flog den vorwärts, rückwärts, oben auf den Kopf, in jede beliebige Richtung. Da gab es aber auch gar keinen Halten.
War er der Weltmeister?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau, welchen Titel er sich eingeheims hat, aber er hat zumindest mit dem Flug, den ich da gerade gesehen habe, alles, was da bei der Veranstaltung abzuräumen war, reingeholt. Aber ich habe es jetzt nicht so mehr genau im Kopf. Mal gucken, vielleicht finde ich das Video jetzt rein zufällig nochmal wieder.
Meinst du im Internet drin?
Das ist natürlich im Internet drin. Im Internet ist alles. Außer dein Blog. Das ist spannend. Warum bist du denn noch nicht Pilot geworden?
Ich kenne Piloten. Ich kenne Piloten. Ich bin auch selber schon in so kleinen Flugzeugen geflogen. Nicht nur mitgeflogen, sondern habe die auch gesteuert. Der Grund, warum ich kein Pilot bin, das hat sicherlich was mit meiner Persönlichkeitsstruktur zu tun. Aber auch mit den Finanzen. Wenn ich mich jetzt wirklich anstrengen würde, dann wäre ich sicherlich in der Lage, mit dem Geld rüberzukommen, das es braucht, um einen Pilotenschein zu machen. Aber hier kommt jetzt meine Persönlichkeitsstruktur ins Spiel. Ich habe so viele andere Sachen zu tun, die mir so viel mehr Spaß machen, als das Geld zu verdienen, was ich brauche, um einen Pilotenschein zu machen. Dass ich es einfach nicht mache.
Das muss man sich ja nicht gut nachvollziehen. Es gibt auch so einige Dinge, die ich nicht tue, auch wenn sie vielleicht ganz interessant zu sein scheinen, weil sie einfach zu teuer sind.
Man muss mit einer gewissen, auch sehr einschränkenden Disziplin ausgerüstet sein, um so etwas zu verfolgen. Ich bewundere natürlich alle Leute, die das machen. Weil was sie dann machen können, ist fantastisch. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich es bedauere über diese Disziplin nicht zu verfügen.
In deinem Buch gibt es auch noch so ein schönes Kapitel. Es sind sogar zwei Kapitel. Das eine befasst sich so ein bisschen mit Hubschrauber in den Mythologien dieser Welt. Dann geht es irgendwie auch noch weiter mit Hubschrauber und Aberglaube. Inwieweit sind denn Hubschrauber an der Stelle mit der Menschheit verbunden?
Ja, also die Mythologien sind natürlich ein weiterer Bereich. Ich fand das als sehr interessant. Ich muss auch hier wieder etwas ausholen zur Idee des Hubschraubers. Ich habe irgendwann festgestellt, dass die Leute, die den Hubschrauber ursprünglich Erdachtung konzipiert haben oder jedenfalls die, die wichtige Entwicklungsmaßnahmen daran gehabt haben, angefangen von Leonardo da Vinci, der das Prinzip festgeschrieben hat und auch den Namen festgelegt hat. Helikopter, also das Wort Helikopter stammt von da Vinci. Er hat das aus zwei griechischen Wörtern zusammengebaut. Helikopter und Pteron, also drehender Flügel. Drehflügler halt. Die haben alle geträumt. Die haben auch immer in dieser Zeit, als alle Dinge tatsächlich noch verbunden waren, der technischen Entwicklung immer noch andere Zuschreibungen gegeben. In diesem Geist wurde der Hubschrauber halt gebaut. Das ging so weit, dass noch in den 60ern ein dann schon richtiger Hubschrauber-Ingenieur, der Arthur Bell, hat quasi seine Hubschrauber gebaut als Teil eines alchemistischen Projektes. Er hat eigentlich was vollkommen anderes versucht zu finden. Aber die einzige Möglichkeit, das in dieser Welt irgendwie zu realisieren, war dann halt die technische Entwicklung des Hubschraubers. Also einerseits mein Interesse an den Mythologien ist tatsächlich begründet in den Geschichten und Gedanken um die Schöpfer des Hubschraubers. Was hat sie umgetrieben außer dem Bau des Hubschraubers? Andererseits natürlich auch in den Mythologien selber. Es gibt ja diese Idee, du hast es schon gesagt, der Hubschrauber ist so etwas wie die von oben kommende Bedrohung, der man nicht ausweichen kann. Es ist immer autonom, es kann plötzlich auftauchen. Es ist aber zugleich diese rettende Größe, die gelben Engel des ADAC, Rettungshubschrauber, die Rettung in letzter Not, das ist auch eine Kraft, die von oben kommt. Das ist immer mitschwingend, das Gotthafte, das Übermenschliche, diese Idee. Alle diese Figuren sind ja nicht erst erfunden worden, um sie dann dem Hubschrauber zuzuschreiben. Es gab sie ja vorher, es gab sie in den Märchen, es gab sie in den Mythologien. Um jetzt da wieder anzuschließen oder dieses neue Thema permanent abzugleichen mit dem, worüber wir vorher schon gesprochen haben, Vietnam in der berühmten Szene des Angriffs auf dieses Dorf spielt halt dieser Körne Wagner-Musik. Aber es ist jetzt nicht irgendein Wagner, es ist halt der Ritt der Valkyren. Und wie so eine mythologische Zuschreibung funktioniert, zeigt Apokalypse Now an dieser Stelle ganz deutlich. Wer sind die Valkyren? Die Valkyren sind halt einerseits die Töchter Odins, aber was ist ihre Funktion? Sie brausen halt auf geflügelten Pferden über dem Schlachtfeld herum und stoßen nieder, wenn irgendwo ein Krieger fällt und nehmen die Seele des Kriegers mit nach Valhall. Das ist auch das, was halt der US-Rettungshubschrauber tut, mit den Verwundeten und den Toten. Also das ist ein ganz klares Beispiel einer Zuschreibung dieser mythischen Schifre. Dieses Beispiel kann man jetzt endlos fortschreiben, was ich beispielhaft halt auch in einem Kapitel in dem Buch gemacht habe. Das heißt nicht, dass das ganze Buch von dort an nur noch einfach eine Fortschreibung, dieses ein Thema ist. Aber ich habe es halt schon derartig elaboriert, dass man die Idee schon kriegt. Also man kann das lustigerweise auch auf alle möglichen Kulturen ausdehnen. Wir befinden uns da selbstverständlich jetzt schon wieder in diesem mythischen Bereich, in dieser Grauzone der Fantasie und der Überlieferung und des Glaubens. Aber die Bilder lassen sich da halt endlos und immer wieder ähnlich evozieren. Also es deutet schon darauf hin, dass gewisse signifikante Muster davor herrschen. Das unterscheidet sich nicht so viel. Man kann das in verschiedene Kategorien einteilen. Und der Hubschrauber belegt halt zwei dieser Kategorien. Einerseits die dunkle Bedrohung, der man nicht entkommen kann, und andererseits die plötzliche und unerwartete Wettung. Das wird halt hin bis in Musikvideos oder in die Werbung ausgespielt. Das ist so eine Gestalt des Hubschraubers, wenn man so will. Ich stelle natürlich auch, sonst wäre es ja auch langweilig, mit dem Buch eine These auf, dass sozusagen das dritte etwas, als das, was nur entstehen kann, wenn die wieder Gegensätze zusammengehen, womit wir wieder bei der Erratik wären, wenn aus dieser totalen Bedrohung oder der Idee der plötzlichen Rettung, wenn das paradox zusammengeht, dann entsteht daraus etwas, wenn wir uns auf dieser mythologischen Ebene weiterbewegen wollen, etwas drittes wird, nämlich die Freiheit. Die Freiheit, über alles selber hinaus zu wachsen und alles selbst erreichen zu können. Quasi selber zum Hubschrauber zu werden oder zu.
Gott.
Gott ist die Omnipotenz. Man kann über sich selbst hinaus wachsen. Gott ist einer, der alles sieht. Was ist, wenn ich Gott bin, ein Hubschrauber mit einer Kamera, der über mir selber fliegt?
Womit wir wieder bei Blue Thunder und dem fliegenden Auge wären.
Absolut. Jetzt haben wir wieder ganz hervorragend. Rotor, das Wort, ist ein Palindrom. Man kann es von vorne und hinten sprechen. Es ist zugleich auch der Ouroboros, die Schlange, die sich immer wieder selber in den Schwanz beißt. Der endlose Kreislauf, vielleicht auch der endlose Kreisgesang, der Engel, die um den Thron des Herrn schwimmen. Man kann diese Bilder endlos fortzeichnen. Und ich habe es schon gesagt, Wiederholung ist natürlich auch inherent in der Kreisbewegung des Rotors. Denn auf diese Art und Weise wird Auftrieb erzeugt. Der Rotor dreht sich permanent. Er beschreibt immer denselben Kreis, aber ist insgesamt doch an einem anderen Punkt im Raum angekommen.
Hast du dich eigentlich in dem Zusammenhang auch mal mit dem speziellen Phänomen der Quadrokopter beschäftigt? Ja, auch Oktokopter.
Das sind zwei Quadrokopter gekoppelt. Die Russen haben das schon gemacht. Die Russen haben angefangen mit dem fantastischen Duokopter Mill 12. Sie haben den Körper ihrer größten Verkehrsmaschine genommen. Zwei der Antriebseinheiten ihrer größten Hubschrauber haben sie an diesem Korpus ihres größten Verkehrsflugzeugs angebaut. Sie haben damit in den 60er-Jahren den bis heute ungebrochenen Höhenlast-Weltrekord aufgestellt. Und den Höhenlastdauer-Weltrekord.
Keiner konnte so hoch, so viel...
Schleppen und so lange. Jetzt geht es immer weiter. Es gibt ja die Mikrokopter inzwischen, aber auch die Mesokopter, also quasi kleine Hubschrauber in Nano-Größe, die von Bakterien, Batterien angetrieben werden. Ach, es ist fantastisch. Und selbstverständlich, die kleinen Dinger können ja gut als Schwarm arbeiten. Und sozusagen diese Quadrokopter, man kann die zusammenkoppeln, dann hat man die Oktokopter. Aber bei den Schwärmen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie da die lateinische Bezeichnung oder die griechische Bezeichnung von so hohen Nummern überhaupt ist. Man müsste das dann nennen so den Multikopter. Oder Multi ist auch nur viel, oder?
Multi ist einfach nur viel.
Einfach nur viel.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen die russische Methode. Der amerikanische Ingenieurswesen konnten sich vor allem immer so viel entgegensetzen. Sie bauten immer alles irgendwie in verdammt groß. Sie bräuchten Transportmaschinen. Diese Hubschrauber mit diesen zwei Rotoren vorne und hinten, das ist ja diese komische gebogene Wurst.
Ja, fliegende Banane, was?
Warum ist denn der überhaupt so komisch geknickt? Ach so, damit der eine höher ist als der andere. Das heißt, die überlappen sich eigentlich?
Die überlappen sich. Es gibt aber auch Intermeshing. Also wir sind jetzt auch, siehst du, wir sind immer noch auf der gleichen Kreisbahn. Wir sind wieder zurück zu dem Design, wo wir vorhin waren.
Jaja, wir drehen uns die ganze Zeit im Kreis. Fantastisch.
Und wir drehen uns immer schneller und immer schneller. Und steigen immer höher und immer höher. Jedenfalls, ja, Intermeshing, das ist ganz interessant. Die verschränken sich tatsächlich beim Drehen. Da sind also nicht die, da ist die Kreisbahn, die eine Kreisbahn nicht über oder unter der anderen angeordnet. Sondern die Dinger sind perfekt synchronisiert, dass sie sich drehen.
Wie Zahnräder.
Genau, wie Zahnräder. Und die sind auch sehr, sehr effektiv. Also das ist mit das effektivste System, was man zum Beispiel im Gebirge einsetzen kann. Ach, warum? Ja, das hat was mit dem Effizienz-Koeffizienten zu tun. Also die Verbrauchung.
Die können ja ab der selben Stelle Druck nach unten machen und sich nicht überlappen.
Genau, die nehmen sich gegenseitig kaum etwas weg, wirken im Gegenteil doppelt auf einen Punkt. Und können natürlich, weil sie das können, auch effizient von so einer Maschine angetrieben werden. Und sind dadurch in Höhenlagen, wo ja weniger Sauerstoff ist, auch leistungsstärker.
Verstehe.
Das sind verschiedene Faktoren. Das ist ja nicht nur so, dass die da oben in die Luft gesprengte Kühe aus der Schlucht ziehen oder den gefällten Hochwald zu Tal transportieren. Nein, sie retten ja auch die von der Lawine verschütteten Snowboarder, die auf den hängen Snowboarden, wo früher diese Wälder gestanden haben.
Hast du so ein bisschen im Blick, was die technische Entwicklung im Hubschrauberbereich, worauf sie sich am meisten konzentrieren?
Das ist interessant. Darüber möchte ich sehr gerne sprechen. Weil es ist sozusagen in der Erratik, die ja auch sich mit Abweichungen und Fehlentwicklungen beschäftigt, es ist fantastisch. Es ist nicht nur so, dass es in die Helikopterforschung als erratische Hauptforschung fällt. Nein, es ist eine tatsächliche Fehlentwicklung oder sogar zwei. Die Russen haben eigentlich alles, was sie im Kalten Krieg entwickelt haben, bis heute fortentwickeln und ganz anständig vermarkten können. Also diese Polen, diese leichten oder mittelschweren Hubschrauber, das sind alles grundsätzliche Designs aus den 60er-Jahren. Die Amis haben, weil sie mehr Geld hatten und auch einfach vorne sein wollten, ständig versucht, man muss grundsätzlich sagen, dass alle Designs schon bekannt sind, teilweise schon seit dem 18. Jahrhundert. Die werden aber nach und nach versucht zu realisieren. Und in den letzten 15 Jahren haben die Amis einerseits das Kipp-Rotorsystem versucht zu perfektionieren. Das ist, wie gesagt, schon sehr alt. Das stammt schon aus der vortechnischen Zeit eigentlich. Das ist dieser sogenannte Osprey. Das heißt, man hat zwei starke Motoren an den Enden der Flüge, die samt den Rotoren gekippt werden. Sie können so gekippt werden. Was heißt das? Das ist Weißkopf-Seeadler, wer das nachschlagen möchte. Das ist das Wappentier der US-Amerikaner. Dieses Fluggerät heißt so, es ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Es hat den zentralen Körper eines großen Militärflugzeugs. Flüge, die nicht ganz so lang sind wie bei einem gewöhnlichen Flugzeug. Und an den Enden dieser Flüge diese großen, gewaltigen Antriebseinheiten. Also schwenkbare Motoren mit Propellern obendrauf, die weder so groß sind wie... Also sie sind mehr wie übergroße Luftschrauben. Sie sehen aus wie richtige Flugzeugpropeller, sind aber viel größer als diese. Aber nicht so groß wie Rotorblätter oder ein Gesamtrotor eines Hubschraubers, ein Hauptrotor. Das ist der Osprey. Die Dinger sollten eigentlich jetzt schon im Irak irgendwie in die Waagschale geworfen worden sein. Das wird nie passieren, weil die halt einfach nicht gut funktionieren. Die Tests, man hat unglaublich viel Kohle damals in diese Entwicklung versenkt und die waren nie stabil. Man hat dann die Spezifikationen immer weiter nach unten geschraubt. Und die Dinger wurden immer unsicherer und es wurde immer mehr Geld in ihre Entwicklung gesteckt. Und schließlich, heute spricht kein Mensch mehr davon. Die gibt es zwar, die werden auch auf diesem Fernsehkanal N24, wo nachts mal ein Militärgerät irgendwie verhandelt wird, immer als die neuste Entwicklung verkauft. Aber das ist schon seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr die neuste Entwicklung. Die werden auch nie kommen, es sei denn, es passiert irgendwie eine unglaubliche Vorwärtsentwicklung in diesem Design. Aber das ist nicht wirklich absehbar. Das Zweite, und das war auch für Irak konzipiert, war der Comanche. Der Comanche sollte die Linie der eigentlichen Schlachthubschrauber, der Amerikaner kommt von der Yuikoba in Vietnam über den Apogee Tank Killer, den man jetzt eigentlich kennt. Das ist tatsächlich ein sehr moderner, sehr effizienter Kampfhubschrauber. Aber eigentlich hatten die Amerikaner was anderes vor. Der Apogee sollte eigentlich jetzt schon wieder veraltet sein oder sollte ersetzt werden durch etwas, was aus dem Apogee entstanden war oder aus dem, was man daraus gelernt hat, nämlich der Comanche. Und der Comanche sollte die Next Generation sein. Also der sollte Stealths haben. Der sollte unglaublich moderne, modifizierte Rotorcraft-Systeme haben. Der sollte sich selber reparieren können nach Treffern und Schadensmeldungen an die Basis funken. Also ein richtig geiles Zukunftskampfmonster. Was sich herausgestellt hat, wenn die Dinger gut gepanzert sind, dann kann man sie nicht so effizient einsetzen, also kosteneffizient einsetzen, wie man das muss, wenn man sie einsetzen will. Wenn sie ungepanzert sind, dann sind sie nichts Neues. Dann kann man sie abschießen, so wie die Hubschrauber, die man jetzt auch hat. Also ist dieses Projekt mindestens für jetzt vom Tisch. Das waren sozusagen die zwei eigentlichen Neuentwicklungen. Daneben hat es an einzelnen Systemkomponenten doch immer wieder Weiterentwicklung gegeben. Also zum Beispiel hier diese Leute von Messerschmitt sind sehr effektiv daran gewesen. Sowohl die, also durch Komponentenbauer, sie haben halt einfach neue Rotorblätter entwickelt. Auch intelligente Rotorblätter, die sich dann halt unterschiedlich verformen, sodass du nicht mehr das gesamte Blatt anstellen musstest, sondern beispielsweise nur das Ende anstellen kannst oder was da im Detail alles gemacht wurde. Kurz und gut, mit dem Zweck, sowohl Treibstoffverbrauch als auch Lärmemission zu verringern. Womit die sehr, sehr erfolgreich waren. Das ist, warum man diese neuen Hubschrauber, die über Berlin fliegen, halt einfach nur als so ein vielleicht sogar angenehmes, aber auf jeden Fall nicht besonders störendes Brummen wahrnimmt. Im Gegensatz zu früher, bis Anfang der 90er, ist auch noch dieser Spirit of Spandau geflogen. Das war die Bell UH-1D. Für die Zuhörer, die im Internet sind, wir sind in Berlin. Wir sprechen jetzt über West-Berlin. Das war ein amerikanischer Hubschrauber, der in Berlin im Rettungsflug eingesetzt wird. Das war einer von diesen Dingern, die immer wirklich viel Lärm gemacht haben. Da habe ich eigentlich erklärt, ihr müsst zurückgehen auf 00125. Wo ich gesagt habe, jetzt in dem Zähler, in dem Podcast. Die Dinger haben mit jeder Umdrehung das Rotor, der bei Rotorblättern so einen Überschallknall produziert.
Und den spart man sich jetzt sozusagen, dass die Rotorblätter sich anders verformen?
Die gab es nur bei diesem Modell aufgrund der spezifischen Konstruktion. Aber bei anderen Hubschraubern, auch älteren, gab es die nicht. Aber die haben trotzdem total viel Lärm gemacht. Diese Forschung mit den Rotorblättern kommt quasi dem Gesamthubschrauberbau zu Gute.
Und heute ist das aber USOS.
Heute sollte das USOS sein, wobei ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das jetzt in die polnischen Hubschrauber eingebaut wird.
Aber so das Problem, man hätte ganz gerne mal einen. Ich habe mal gehört, es gibt einen... Habt mal gehört, mir fällt gerade ein, das ist verdammt lange her. Ich hörte. Wo ich das mal gehört habe, das muss noch in 80er Jahren gewesen sein, dass es auch meditär Hubschrauber gibt, die wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr leise sind, die sozusagen dafür gebaut sind.
Die berühmte Flüstertechnik. Das gibt es in dem Film mit Mel Gibson, wo er so auch von schwarzen Hubschraubern verfolgt wird. Dort wird es appliziert als tatsächlich die Technologie. Also die geheimagenten, die schwarzen Männer, die in diesen unverkehrten schwarzen Hubschraubern unterwegs sind, können, das wird in dem Film gezeigt, in dem Hubschrauber einen Hebel umlegen, und der Hubschrauber wird total leise. Genau, eben noch Frap, Frap, Frap, Frap. Die gleiche Technik. Silent Mode hatte ja der Airwolf bzw. sein Vorläufer Blue Thunder. Das ist eine absolut fantastische, in Hollywood entwickelte Hubschrauber-Technologie.
Die es aber nicht wirklich gibt.
Der Airwolf hatte doch auch noch so einen komischen Turbomod, wo er dann immer mit so Jet-Sound durch die Gegend gedüstet ist.
Das allerdings gibt es. Also der Jet-Sound sollte beim Airwolf ja darauf hindeuten, dass er jetzt seine Zusatzjets angeworfen hat. Und Hubschrauber mit Zusatzjets hat man durchaus in den 16ern und 17ern betrieben, um halt höhere Geschwindigkeiten zu erzeugen. Was auch ging, aber das ist ja dann letztlich nicht wirtschaftlich. Man muss ja da irgendwo auch immer eine Ratio finden.
Aber man kann ihm schon beliebig eigentlich Schuss geben, wenn man die Kohle hat.
Man kann ihm, wenn man die Kohle hat, kann man halt zusätzlich noch eine Turbine einbauen. Also ich meine, die Turbinen-getriebenen, Jet-getriebenen Hubschrauber, der können auch Vortrieb mit Jet-Vortrieb erzeugen. Der Rotor bleibt der Rotor und sorgt für den Auftrieb.
Dann habe ich noch gesehen, also ich glaube, in diesem Markt, der ja auch nicht gerade klein ist, günstige Privat-Hubschrauber, gibt es auch ein Modell, wo auf die Schraube hinten verzichtet wird, stattdessen da mit Luft gearbeitet wird. Also sozusagen Druckluft, ein Hauptrotor, nach hinten und dann jeweils nach links und rechts einfach weggekanalisiert wird.
Das ist das Reaktionsmodell, das habe ich vorhin schon kurz angesprochen. Das war dieses Stichwort Wasserstoffperoxid.
Ich dachte, das bezog sich auf den Hauptrotor.
Ja, das ist immer der Hauptrotor.
Ich meine, anstatt des hinteren Heckflügelrotors.
Das ist ein ähnliches Prinzip. Man kann natürlich auf den Heckrotor verzichten, indem man einen starken Luftstrom austreten lässt. Das ist sozusagen nochmal eine Mischung. Das ist auch ein Part-Reaktionsantrieb. Dort wird mit Reaktion, also mit Druckluft und Gegendruck, der Gegendruck erzeugt, den normalerweise die Heckschraube erzeugt. Also eine weitere Hybridform.
Ist das jetzt etwas ganz Tolles?
Das macht es natürlich auch leiser. Es hat ja weniger bewegliche Teile. Aber die Technik ist relativ aufwendig, weil Vorrichtungen zum Erzeugen dieses starken Druckluftstroms auch in den Hubschrauber mit eingebaut werden müssen. Ich bin in so einem Teil selber mal geflogen und der Pilot sagte, es wäre wirklich total wunderbar, es wäre viel leichter zu fliegen, weil dieser Luftstrom auch besser zu steuern wäre. Ich selber habe jetzt keinen Unterschied zu gewöhnlichen Hubschraubern feststellen können. Es ist halt leiser und es vibriert weniger. Aber das ist das Gleiche, es ist leiser, weil es weniger vibriert, weil es weniger bewegliche Teile hat.
Und dann ist mir vor ein paar Tagen auch noch so ein Video wieder mal im Netz, du weißt schon, dieses Internet, über den Weg gelaufen, wo so ein Mann einfach nur unten so eine Haltegriffstange, zwei Stück, hatte, die wie so eine Antenne links und rechts rausgehen und unten noch so ein Bügel, auf den er sich draufsetzen konnte, das war sozusagen alles, also einfach nur links und rechts, ein Haltegriff, wie so ein Flugdrachen im Prinzip. Und er konnte sich dann draufsetzen und da drüber hatte er so zwei gegeneinander rotierende Rotoren und das war alles und damit konnte er fliegen. Das war nicht besonders elegant, das war mehr so eine Tech-Demonstration, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, aber es flog, ohne dass er jetzt noch so ein Gegen-Rotor hatte. Den spart man sich, wenn man zwei hat?
Den spart man sich, wenn man zwei hat, genau.
Und ist das irgendwie eine viable Geschichte, dass wir demnächst alle so unseren Rucksack-Mini-Rotor zum Ausklappen, so wie Gamma damals irgendwie bei Mickey Mouse? Kennst du den eigentlich? Kennst du bestimmt auch, oder? Der mit dem kompletten Hubschrauber irgendwie aus seiner Schürze zu?
Es ist auf jeden Fall. Also, das ist ja das gleiche wie Basejumping. Wenn jetzt demnächst die Basejumper anfangen, nicht mit einem Schirm vom höchsten Gebäude der Welt runterzuspringen, sondern halt mit einem Rucksack-Fahrtwind angetriebenen Rotor-Umschnellgerät oder Umschnellrotor, dann wird genau das passieren, was du jetzt gesagt hast. Dann wäre das halt schon mal das Modell des individualen Hubschraubers. Ob das dann jeder macht, ist dafür zweifelt werden. Nicht jeder schnallt sich so ein Ding um und springt vom höchsten Gebäude der Welt. Der eigentliche Individualhubschrauber ist halt auch ein Versprechen, das im Endeffekt seit dem 15. Jahrhundert, seit Leonardo da Vinci, auf dem Tisch ist. Lange hat es niemanden interessiert in dem Moment, wo er in den Bereich der Mythologie wiederverbannt. Das ist ja wieder das gleiche, der Individualflug. Ich meine, die Hexe, die sich am Blocksberg auf dem Besen schwingt und damit losfliegt, das ist ja schon der Individualhubschrauber. Es ist halt jetzt ein anderes System, aber im Prinzip geht es hier um genau die gleichen Sachen. Tatsächlich will der Mensch fliegen, aber er hat keine Flüge, also was macht er? Er denkt, er träumt vom Individualflug. Das schlägt sich nieder in Schokoladenbildchen oder hier so Zigarettensammelbildchen, wo dann in Berlin von 1912 mit Flügen ausgestattete Polizisten, mit Flügen ausgestattete Schokoladendiebe jagen. Das wurde von Boros schon polemisch gegen die Maschine verwendet, als er sagte, wo sind denn die Individualhubschrauber, die er uns versprochen hat? Medial wird es begleitet von der gesamten Presse. Man kann da keine Unterschiede mehr machen zwischen Regenbogenpresse oder Yellowpress und den sogenannten seriösen Blättern. In der Regenbogenpresse ist es immer eine halbe Seite mit aufwendigen Zeichnungen und einer schönen Frau, die ein Modell präsentiert. In der seriöseren Presse ist es halt so aus aller Welt oder ferner liefen. Haha, hier ist das nächste Modell des Individualhubschraubers. Dann kostet das vor der Währungsumstellung 65.000 Mark. Und dann zwei Jahre später ist schon wieder ein neues Modell des Individualhubschraubers auf dem Markt, was dann so leicht zu bedienen wie ein MOFA ist und dann 35.000 Euro kostet. Oder manchmal ist es teurer, wenn es eine geschlossene Kabine hat und so weiter. All diese Sachen, bis in die kleinste denkbare Verästelung, sind halt untersucht und in diesem Buch niedergeschlagen. In verschiedene Wege der Analyse oder verschiedene Richtungen, die unterschiedliche Thesen nehmen, habe ich jetzt mal kurz angerissen. Aber es ist alles natürlich dort bei Weitem fundierter dargestellt, als ich das jetzt in dieser Zeit hier und ad hoc...
Ja, unsere Zeit läuft auch ein bisschen aus.
Aus dem Nähkästchen.
Jetzt würde ich aber doch ganz gerne noch mal wissen, was ist denn dein Lieblingshubschrauber? Hast du sowas?
Ja, ich schätze, ich habe sowas, aber darüber möchte ich jetzt hier im Internet nicht sprechen.
Oh Gott, das war jetzt eine zu private Frage.
Das ist doch ziemlich privat.
Okay, dann frage ich anders. Was sind denn so die prägendsten Hubschrauber-Modelle, die sich prägen im Sinne von die jetzt vielleicht die Menschheit oder das Kulturphänomen Hubschrauber am meisten geprägt hat? Also wir hatten schon das Modell aus dem Vietnamkrieg. Was war das nochmal gleich?
Bell-Juie kann man den so...
Dann gibt es den auch schon erwähnten Apache-Meditärhubschrauber, der so ein bisschen der Inbegriff des Militärhubschraubers heutzutage ist. Also natürlich sind vor allem dann die Militärhubschrauber so ein Ding. Dann halt die berühmten Hubschrauber aus Fernsehserien. Das ist ja irgendwie sehr prägend. Wir hatten schon den Airwolf, wir hatten das fliegende Auge. Das waren unterschiedliche Modelle.
Interessant könnte man vielleicht noch den Clint Eastwood-Film Der Wolf hetzt die Meute. Das ist, ich weiß jetzt den englischen Titel nicht. Man kann da mal vielleicht selber im Internet nachschauen. Der Wolf hetzt die Meute. Da gibt es eine ganz entscheidende Szene. Also Clint Eastwood wird verfolgt von einem Hubschrauber mit Ganoven drin und kann sich schließlich in die Wüste retten. Der Hubschrauber verfängt sich in Überlandleitungen und stürzt ab, geht mit einem Feuerball auf und fällt zu Boden. Während diese Szene beobachtet, Clint Eastwood mit seiner Blondine hinten auf dem Motorrad. Das Motorrad ist ein besonders amerikanisches Motorrad, was man im allgemeinen Sprachbau auch Chopper nennt. Genau, und worauf ich jetzt hinaus will, ist natürlich die Doppelbedeutung des Wortes Chopper. Im englischen Slang nennt man den Hubschrauber einen Chopper. Da kommt der Chopper. Natürlich nennt man aber auch dieses Motorrad-Chopper. Ich hatte vorher schon mal... Es gibt diese...
Tightrope heißt der Film auf Engel.
Der Wolf hetzt die Meute.
Ja, das war so die Zeit, wo Übersetzungen Sinn gemacht haben.
Tightrope mit Clint Eastwood. Und es gibt ja zum Beispiel, über diesen Begriff, ich hab's vorhin kurz gesagt, gelber Engel. Die ursprünglichen gelben Engel waren ja Motorradfahrer. Das waren die Motorradfahrer des ADAC in den 60ern. Die waren ja lange, bevor es überhaupt diese Hubschrauber gab, Rettungssubschrauber oder überhaupt Hubschrauber, die vom ADAC betrieben wurden, gab es ja schon die gelben Engel. Das waren Motorradfahrer. Jetzt ist diese gelbe Engelzuschreibung ja sozusagen... Erstens gibt es diese Motorradfahrer nicht mehr, weil die alle in so Kombis unterwegs sind. Und zweitens ist diesezuschreibung gelber Engel ja auf die ADAC-Hubschrauber übergegangen, beziehungsweise auf die Luftrettung in den einzelnen Städten, die alle Christof heißen, egal wo. Und diese Bezirklichkeit, Chopper, Chopper, gibt es noch mal in dem Begriff des Choppers als Motorrad und des Choppers als Hubschrauber. Allerdings kann man nicht wirklich etwas daraus lernen. Man kann es nur als Denkfigur hinnehmen. Der Hubschrauber wird Chopper genannt, weil er wie ein Hackbeil mit seinen Klingen die Luft zerschneidet. Während der Chopper runtergestrippt, Chopped-off ist. Da hat man etwas abgeschnitten. Die ursprünglichen Chopper waren Chopped. Man hat alles überflüssige abgenommen, um sie leichter zu machen. Das ist jetzt noch mal diese Art von Mendy-Information für unsere Internet-Zuhörer.
Ja, das ist das, worum es geht. Mit technischen Details kann man sich ja auch mal zu lesen. Aber die kulturellen Aspekte sind gut. Dafür gucke ich nochmal, ob mir noch ein paar andere Hubschrauber einfallen. Mir fällt noch ein der Hubschrauber, der zum Einsatz kam in der großartigen amerikanischen Fernsehserie, Magnum.
Oh, mit diesem Hubschrauber bin ich tatsächlich in Hawaii geflogen.
Echt mit dem Island Hopper. Wie hieß noch gleich der Fahrer?
TC, ja, das steht für Theodor Calvin, wo wir schon mal dabei sind.
Genau. Was ist denn das für ein Hubschrauber?
Es ist ein Hughes. H-U-G-H-E-S 500. Das war das Urmodell. Das ist die klassische Form des freundlichen Hubschraubers.
Genau.
Das sind übrigens auch ganz erfolgreiche No-Tars, was du vorhin angesprochen hast. Die haben es geschafft, aus diesem Hubschrauber einen effizienten ohne Heckrotor, nur mit Druckluftheck zu bauen. Inzwischen heißt es nicht mehr Hughes, sondern McDonnell Douglas. Aber ich selber benutze immer die Bezeichnung der ursprünglichen Modelle.
Klar.
Und nicht die aktuellen Industrie-Konglomerats-Namen.
Ja, natürlich. Das machen wir im Computerbereich auch nicht anders.
Um nochmal auf besondere Hubschrauber hinzukommen, ich bleibe jetzt mal weiter in dieser Dualität. Man kennt ja Herbie den tollen Käfer, das war damals eine bekannte Disney-Produktion. Die wenigsten Leute wissen, dass es damals eine bundesdeutsche Counter gegeben hat. Und zwar Dudu, ein total verrückter Käfer. Und dieser Dudu konnte sich auch in einen Hubschrauberkäfer, also auf Art eines Hubschraubers fliegenden Käfer verwandeln. Womit er allerdings auch zurück oder rekurrierte auf den berühmten Film Chitty Chitty Bang Bang, so ein Musicalfilm, dort konnte das Fahrzeug des Erfinders Professor Potts sich auch in einen Hubschrauber verwandeln. Also die Idee, da sind wir dann schon sofort wieder im Bereich des Verwandlungsaspektes. Also etwas, was sich aus einem Auto in einen Hubschrauber verwandeln kann. So soll es sich dann nicht ebenso gut gleich in ein Unterseeboot oder ein UFO verwandeln. Was sich verwandeln kann, kann sich eben verwandeln. Das ist die Natur der Fähigkeit, sich zu verwandeln.
Interessanterweise, also die allwissende Müllhalde, also die Wikipedia, sagt, dass die Idee eines computergesteuerten Superautos, und die bezieht es sich auf den Dudu, Inspiration gewesen sein soll für Night Rider, was ja auch so ein bisschen was wie Airwolf hat.
Ja, Night Rider ist quasi der Airwolf als...
Es ist auch immer so dieses Mann, Maschine, so der Pilot und sein Gerät, wie bei Airwolf, das ist irgendwie auch eine ganz starke Geschichte. Ich glaube, du hast in deinem Buch auch so ein Ding mit Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Mit Arnold, genau, genau.
Was steckt dahinter?
Ja, das ist halt die Idee der Menschmaschine, bzw. ist halt nur eine weitere Spiel- oder Lesart, wenn man so will, dieser Dichotomie, die halt in das Dritte übergeht, von der ich vorhin gesprochen habe. Schwarzenegger, der sich ja quasi als Mann und als Mensch selbst vergöttlicht. Sein erster Film, da konnte er natürlich mal Englisch sprechen, da hat er einen griechischen Gott in New York gespielt. Er hat einen griechischen Gott in New York gespielt. Das war tatsächlich sein erster Film. Er kommt nach New York, aber er ist ein griechischer Gott. Er findet ein Zuhause in der Bodybuilder-Bewegung, die zu der Zeit ein unglaubliches Vehikel ist. Arnold Schwarzenegger ist zu Recht dort, wo er jetzt ist. Der Mann ist verdammt noch mal auf kulturellem Gebiet ein Genie. Und auf dem Gebiet der Körpermodifikation und der Verwandlungsfähigkeit. Das würde jetzt vielleicht wirklich zu weit führen. Man muss halt sehr genau das Övre des Schwarzenegger lesen, dann kann man da gewisse Undercurrents freilegen.
Aber was ist das denn mit Hubschraubern zu tun?
Er wird ja auch dieser Hubschrauber-Pilot in vielen... Er verwandelt seine quasi am Anfang seiner Filmkarriere angelegte Selbstvergöttlichung, wird erfüllt bis in dem Film End of Days. Bis dahin gibt es noch andere Filme, in denen Hubschrauber eine Rolle spielen. Und jeder Film... Ja, ich spreche ausschließlich von Schwarzenegger-Filmen und den Aspekten der körperlichen Verwandlung bzw. der Entwicklung der Figur Schwarzenegger unter besonderer Berücksichtigung der Beziehung zum Hubschrauber, wie sie in den einzelnen Filmen, die diese einzelnen Schritte darstellen, gezeigt werden. Das Stichwort ist... Fliegt Gott einen Hubschrauber oder die Menschmaschine?
Ja, und ist Arnold Schwarzenegger...
Arnold Schwarzenegger ist nicht Gott, aber er ist ein Gott.
Ein griechischer Gott, wie wir gelernt haben.
Ja, fallen dir noch weitere... Mir fallen jetzt gerade keine weiteren populären Hubschrauber mehr ein. Irgendwann hatte ich noch im Kopf...
Das... Also im Märchen 1001 Nacht, das geflügerte Pferd, das ist auch ein Hubschrauber.
Ach, ja.
Da gibt es sogar einen Auf- und Abstiegshebel. Was sich jetzt gerade gemacht... Na ja, also... Was in 1001 Nacht geschieht?
Ja.
Also es ist ja so... Die ganze Geschichte?
Heinrich Dubel Märchen aus 1001 Nacht. Nein, aber das geflügerte Pferd habe ich noch so eine vage Erinnerung. Aber dass das jetzt ein Hubschrauber ist, ist mir neu.
Na ja, man muss die Texte halt mal lesen. Dort ist ein Pferd, was einen Auf- und Abstiegshebel hat. Und dann Karlsson vom Dach. Da haben wir das europäische Pendant eines Eigenflieger-Verwandlers. Man hat nicht das individuale Flugzeug, man fliegt individual.
Man ist Hubschrauber.
Ja, man ist Hubschrauber, genau.
Stimmt, der klappt hinten auf seinem Rücken raus. Ja, auf Knopfdruck. Da kommt der Hubschrauber raus. Und Karlsson kommt über die Dachung.
Schade, ich habe mit der Ansage über das Märchen von 1001 in der Nacht eine berühmte Aufnahme von Ernst Bloch paraphrasiert. Im Ton habe ich versucht, das nachzumachen, so wie er das sagt. Aber ich muss sagen, du kannst das ja vielleicht in der Postproduktion am Schluss an diesen Podcast ranhängen. Wenn ich dir später per diesen MP3-File das Internet mit der E-Mail zuschicke.
Das sollte möglich sein.
Dann können die Leute zurückgehen auf, wo sind wir denn jetzt.
Die müssen jetzt einfach nur warten, bis der Jingle abgelaufen ist. Und dann kommt das.
Aber sie müssen doch zurückgehen, um meine Paraphrase zu hören, um es zu vergleichen zu können.
Das ist das Tolle am Podcast. Man kann immer wieder hin und zurück und vor spulen, bis man verrückt wird.
Podcast, das ist auch so eine neue Technologie, habe ich mir sagen lassen. Man hat sozusagen jetzt ein Gerät, was Port heißt, so wie zum Beispiel der von Apple, wo ich jetzt nicht sage, wie der in Wirklichkeit heißt. Aber Port basically. Und dann tut man den irgendwie mit dem Internet zusammen.
Richtig? Das ist richtig.
Und dann geht das Podcast in den Port rein.
Richtig.
Und dann hört man sich das an, wie man früher im Autoradio, Luftradio gehört hat.
Genau. Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man möchte, weil es ja aufgenommen ist. Und man kann Pause drücken.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und wenn ich sage, irgendwie komplizierter Begriff, dann drückt der erfahrene Podcast-Hörer jetzt auf die Pause-Taste. Und in diesem Moment, wo ich weiter rede, sind schon wieder zwei Minuten vergangen und er weiß schon alles darüber.
Weil das Internet es ihm gesagt hat.
Ja. Und das Internet bietet ja, wie wir wissen, die Wahrheit. Also zumindest eine der möglichen.
Die einzige Wahrheit über das Internet, die nicht stimmt, ist, dass es Internet heißt. Es heißt nämlich sogenanntes Internet.
Das kann sein.
Oder wie wir bei uns am Institut sagen, das Zwedenborg.
Das Zwedenborg?
Das Zwedenborg mit ZV. Das Zwedenborg.
Ist das jetzt nur so ein aus der Luft gegriffener Name?
Bei uns am Institut heißt das sogenannte Internet Zwedenborg.
Sollten wir das jetzt einfach so für sich stehen lassen oder muss ich das jetzt noch hinterfragen?
Du kannst ja deine Internet-Freunde bitten, einen Wikipedia-Eintrag zu machen.
Das ist natürlich wahr. Okay, dann würde ich sagen, dabei belassen wir es mal. Heinrich, Rosa, wir haben es im Kasten, das war Chaosradio Express Nummer 74, was ich ausführlich mit dem kulturellen Phänomenen des Hubschraubers und weniger dem technischen Phänomenen damit beschäftigt hat. Das war auch Sinn der Sache, vielen Dank für die Teilnahme und ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Ja, das war's und wie immer findet ihr ausführliche Links und da werden dieses Mal einige zusammengekommen sein. Sag ich mal, jetzt schon der Zukunft sozusagen vorausgreifend. Die finden sich unter chaosradio.ccc.de, auf unserem Chaosradio-Portal und natürlich auch in den Lyrics dieses mp3-Datei und was möchtest du mir mit den Zeichen sagen? Du kannst auch einfach die Wahrheit sagen.
Ich wollte noch sagen, danke Tim.
Bitte schön.
Und schönen guten Abend Internet.
Okay, dann verabschiede ich mich auch. Das war's bei Chaosradio Express. Ah ja, und ihr müsst natürlich auch unbedingt wieder Feedback schicken, entweder auf unserem Blog, blog.chaosradio.ch, cc.de, oder ihr schickt uns ein E-Mail, chaosradio.ch, cc.de. Jetzt habe ich es gesagt, ihr wisst ja, wo ihr uns findet. Und ich hoffe, ihr bleibt uns treu. Bis zum nächsten Mal bei Chaosradio Express.